[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you guys hear me this is a testing
20 minutes till launch 20 minutes till
showdown testing the audio making sure
you guys can hear me
i'll be checking the chat to see what
the response is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christopher you better have that same
energy when this podcast starts man
i better see that same energy in the
chat when this podcast starts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i appreciate the super chat uh five
dollar super chat from
how you pronounce his name again
i definitely butchered it still look man
they know i can't pronounce stuff man
get your popcorn ready king is about to
be in
rare form great night of fights last
night boxing and mma
solve i hope you watched youtube cog uh
king did
i clearly can definitely watch that
we'll be going live here uh momentarily
guys we'll be going live for a moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
while i'm proud to announce that the
iron lords podcast will once again be
giving away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain if you're
already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console and if you
support us
on both platforms you have two ballots
to win this amazing console
as you also have two ballots to win an
xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the iron lords podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lords podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us on both
platforms you'll have two ballots for
each system
to win either a playstation 5 console or
of course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lords podcast are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
go what's up everybody and welcome to
episode
178 of the iron lord podcast i am your
host
once again lord sovereign and i'll be
honest with you guys man
i don't even know why we're having a
podcast today because honestly
it was a very slow news week i i think
you all could agree nothing
and nothing at all happened this week so
i we're just here to just you know shoot
the breeze and
have fun
so what's up everybody welcome to the
round table here on the lord's
day we will have uh the boss lord
cognito joining us uh
in progress so guys
quick reminder before we get into into
the the role of show
as you saw my uh my intro there like
we're coming down to the final weeks of
these
uh contests the final week so guys if
you have not
joined the realm either on patreon or
youtube
get it done get in there
i'm hearing somebody else's uh voice
so guys definitely uh we're coming down
to the last couple of weeks of this if
you want to get in on this please
go join the patreon go to the youtube
channel so you guys can have multiple
entries to win both of these consoles
all right
so before we get into uh the
introductions of the three lords that
are here
let me get to these super chats because
you know how you know how what happens
with these super chats
so we have lord tazuichi with the five
dollar super chat hey saab remaxes with
thank frankie negron
oscar de leon jose rojo cecilia cruz
tito puente and many more
just sing
so i will leave i'll leave those
technicalities to king and attic they're
the ones that do the magic behind the
scenes they can they
they could they can adjust that as
necessary
uh then we have lord tempest son with
the five dollar super chat
shout out to the lords love you guys
have an awesome show
then we have lord smitty smith with the
two dollar super chat there is no
greater power than
x the book of x and then last but not
least we have pixel bit g
with the two dollar super chat looking
forward to king clowning port
beggars oh my god please kind
of please we got the heat early in the
chat
let's get into these intros first off we
have
the co-host of the iron lords podcast
and the young wolf of the ilp
lord addict what's going on brother
i agree
i just wanted to hear i did this week
for specifically why addicts said that
because there's so much smoke oh it's to
the point like you're gonna have
your fanboys on either side of the
argument that's fun to watch right
and there was damage control oh my god i
don't watch anybody
bro all of a sudden all of a sudden
people are worried about the state of
the industry
oh my god bro
bro it you know but you know
so that's uh what have you been playing
man uh
i've been playing not a whole lot
actually i've been playing destiny
i've been playing a lot of uh my switch
and actually i've been playing a lot of
dead by daylight here
lately oh i heard it's been lit over
there with that man what's up
anything new no that's that's about all
cause
cause like i said i've been watching so
much
podcast time
[Laughter]
[Music]
just a little destiny not too much just
a little destiny why is that cause it
was a game passer you got everything
no i have not booted that up one time on
the console until i get that x until i
get that 60 frames
i refuse all right are you fat all right
so let's get these super chats before we
move on first off we have sin vendetta
with the question for king
hey king do you have any gambit statues
um let me tell you something sideshow's
uh gambit statue uh
forced me to readjust my uh lineup
and uh made me uh cancel
out my iron studio sentinel dorama
it was three sentinels there was 1800
each and had a bunch of uh x-men around
them
made me uh dropped that line and i
went uh solely for the one-fourth
uh x-men line and that gambit statue is
inbound i will be doing the kos about
that and you hit it right on the head i
know you saw it
apologies king they're saying that
addict's mic is off no that looks fun
i can't hear attic they're saying you're
muted yeah
no they should know someone they're
they're saying they can hear me now i
fixed it okay you fixed it okay got you
guys
my bad i was reading away and the xm the
xm studio one
is is a decent entry but i think the
sideshow one
destroys it so yeah it's it's inbound
okay cool excellent so uh let's have uh
put them crest in the chat for the
newest member of the realm darnell
tavares
welcome to the realm sir that's a wrong
name
i don't know don't know was it that
playstation pod that that that sound
that sounds like something that would
kill me in destiny
all right then we have carlos staller
with the two pound super chat i believe
gotta love jim the dancing pinocchio
ryan baby
i think that's hot
[Music]
there we have stitch with the five
dollar super chat we gather here today
to listen to the word of the prophet
lord king david
who did that what was funny is i was in
a discord with press start
uh and i was talking to blaze i was like
yo like
i didn't think i could manage king last
week
i was like this ain't nothing to compare
what king will be this week
bro listen for me i was like i don't
know if i'm feeling this profit thing
but
you can't you gotta give it to king this
your king
wow wow because know you know what it is
we'll get into it but
he bet on this man from the rip
no budging no nothing no budget
and what can you say he's gonna go down
as the greatest xbox ceo period
i and i don't disagree there's one more
step that he's going to do and
that's what it's just going to be like
foot to the throat
this is the throat there we have let's
see i have lord [ __ ] with the five
dollar super chat celebrating my dirty
30 with the lords
oh man congratulations happy birthday
let me take a sip of this
hydration uh watermelon water
this is not juice this is a straight
watermelon water let's give it a cr
uh i had to do like king now and start
taking knees because time is taking my
uh i know the feeling my brother i know
the feeling hold on
boogie man with the five dollar super
chat all hail lord king david the
prophet who foretold of the ascension of
phil dominance maximus aurelius spencer
yes sir then we have jd gamer with the
five dollar super chat all these
bethesda beggars in the street
hashtag no fallout
[Laughter]
then we have [ __ ] once again with the
two dollars super chat king ain't a
profit he just smart and listening
you know you know i see how how close
mario is this week i don't know how i
feel about that
yo you know what i came in here and i
had i found him
hiding miss in his little uh
he's literally right beside him look he
had this in his little jump suit he's
like
yeah that's why his pain is still like
that
get out of your hand you little weird
dude he's like
hey but that's that
all right let me here we got boys i got
tony bryant with the five dollar super
chat the twitter ether post was amazing
yeah it was definitely some ether
thank you then we have night music with
the four dollar super chat good morning
to you as well
sir drink that coffee then we have
mariano pompa shout out to mariano pompa
for putting me on blast on uh on twitter
for nada for not speaking more
i want to hear from you today dude i'm
hosting how much more do you want me to
talk
because you're too quiet on twitter uh
we all know today is king's show so
solid attic get your ball a little
before king takes over yeah we
we have to put king in his rightful
place you know he's gonna have
he's gonna have his for sure the wait is
over
then we have smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat how can you trust a
man who can't look you in the eye
jim stance moves ryan ryan eyes don't
even line up
how is that a verse in the book of x yo
that is
so true that's why i didn't trust
mark cerny when i met him yeah
i don't know if it's personality
whatever but he doesn't really like
talking to
fans of what i like i don't know he
likes to scream his little magic words
when he's standing in front of fake
crowds that they little ep thing
he's like very very high and by uh from
what
i've learned so of course we have
the king of the iron lords podcast
beloved what's up brother what's going
on
well did you have an eventful week or
was it this week was
amazing it was absolutely amazing but
did i do the turn the beat around for
more night
last week right did i no i don't think
so no no no no
no no i think mario was on it last week
wow kos is up right now if you haven't
seen it go check it out um
if you don't know about moon knight i
give a deep dive into
who the character is what he's about how
i learned about the character and
my uh um admiration for the character to
be honest with you or why i chose to
have him in my collection
and what is his meaning and what is his
stance in my collection so
uh this week combat talk oh my god oh
let's let's let real real quickly let's
get through with the
the jamel charlo and jamal charlo jamal
charlo
was on the undercard uh and he's the
middleweight champion the wbc
middleweight champion and they're trying
to do everything under the sun to get
him
off of that title uh
because he wants to rip off canelo's
head so they had him fight
sergey devanchenko and sergey
devlinchenko
is what we can say is the russian hitman
assassin
he fought that guy and they were
pitching a war it started to heat up by
the
the second and third round and uh
i gotta say i thought that was going to
be jamal
charlo's uh hardest test and it proved
to be so
uh because sergey was not
moving he wanted to fight he wanted to
engage he usually throws 60 punches
around
and jamal usually throws 40 punches
around
and it definitely bear fruit that he uh
lowered uh sergey's output
while he was delivering hard shots did
you get a chance to check out that
fights off
i basically checked out the two
basically the main events both brothers
um and yeah like the fight with sergey
like it was just
it was one of those things like i i
expected it to go the distance
what up like check my channel yes
morning
[Laughter]
did you get a chance to watch any of
those combat uh those fights last night
i saw the uh the ufc all right okay so
we're gonna get to you in a second
all right so um yeah don't be ready i
guess okay so
uh about the jamal fight uh what did you
think about it
i think i think it was a great test for
him because like you said
he's a hit man so he's the type that
he's kind of the
the gatekeeper he he is a gatekeeper of
sorts
he's a dude that's going to take
punishment and he's going to he's going
to test your stamina
he's going to test every aspect of your
game to see if you're ready to move on
forward and i think charlo passed it
with flying colors and then
of course his brother you know i'll let
you get into that fight before all right
so uh meryl tarlow uh
he's really known as the the the smaller
brother
and only because of the weight classes
right because they're twins right
they're basically uh identical uh except
for the tattoos
you really have to see them with their
shirts off uh pause
in order to know who to see yeah they
really are identical though they're
completely identical and their
personalities are so much the same
um and i thought this was going to be a
huge chess
uh test for jamel
uh because i thought banana
uh well
yeah his nickname is banana he's
dominican he's a hard worker
uh he's a strong fighter from the
dominican republic
he has great fundamentals his jab
his right hand his left hook his
movement is always spot on
very very decent power very underrated
defense
and uh i thought that because when he
knocked out j-rock
um that showed me a lot in his in his
repertoire
because how he moved around j-rock and
how he implied the pressure so i wanted
to see how
uh jermell jamal will uh know jamel
will actually deal with that and jamelle
dropped him in the first round i think
he dropped him in the fifth round and
finished him off in the eighth
and those punches that he hit him with
they were telling shots because he has
terrible power in both hands he reminds
me of uh terry norris
um terrible terry remember yes and
he has a chip on it who got punched in
the body and damn near dying yeah
let me interrupt you guys for one second
it looks like we got a
we we got a lord visiting the room
i was like well you know they're talking
about ufc's like i like ufc
we could talk about that i was like i'm
gonna come on too
much yeah what's up guys what's up
what's up what's going on man we got the
young lord the young
gunner in the gaming industry analysis
business lord benji sales joining us
thank you sir for coming in did you get
a chance to watch the fight yesterday or
not uh
i watched the ufc i didn't get a chance
to see any of the boxing but i did get a
chance to see the ufc
we're going to go into the ufc in one
more second uh we're just finishing up
so
uh solve what was your take on uh jamel
oh
yo he looks so strong man he looks so
strong he looked fast
he was the short check hooks inside in
the dirty boxing and then also keeping
the distance
and the fact that he finished it off
with a body shot to the gut
not even a ripper punch a straight body
shot to the gut
you know both of these brothers man have
got they they've considerably gotten
better
they've both taken their losses in
stride and learn from them in ways that
sometimes boxers don't do
you know sometimes they don't come back
from these losses um
well he's the only one with a loss yeah
that's right the other way i remember
it was you know the other one is just
actively trying to kill people but go
ahead
but but both of them sort of face
adversity
whether it be in judging or whether
actually you're losing a fight
so uh they've taken it in stride they've
learned they've done they've done what
they're supposed to do
um so sky's the limit for them both man
it was very it was good to watch a paper
boxing pay-per-view first 79
i got that
in these economic terms they need the
call
they got sony game prices
so many game prices that's crazy
obviously
you know after dominic's performance
versus jon jones
you can make an argument that he would
have won on decision or points right
you know he i i thought he was the
overwhelming favorite right there was no
way
i felt he would just not not show he
looked like he didn't show up
and none he really impressed me you know
power in his hands to set up his
techniques he's very aggressive
you know so it just i watched the fight
and i was just very
surprised that dominic i don't know if
he just he didn't have that instinct in
him like he just couldn't push the
button i don't know what it was
and to see him finished i'm like wow
so that was the first that was my first
take on that and then um
actually i let benji jump in as far as
that fight absolutely what did you think
about that fight
yeah it was really jean showing his
power
you know he always he always talks about
after his fights his legendary polish
power
yes and uh it came through in that fight
he broke
dominic's nose badly badly
yeah the kicks to the body his the the
welts on the side i think
uh i agree with you uh that dominic just
didn't
quite look like he showed up he never
looked loose to me he always looked real
tight and uh and i think he started
feeling that power and it made him even
a little bit more gun shy than he kind
of already was
yeah i've noticed like a lot of people
that like watch ufc
they don't really grab a concept on how
much that stuff
hurts when you get hit in those areas
they just act like oh if it's not in the
head it's not for me yeah it's like
it's like especially when you get kicked
in like the shin
and stuff like that hurts so much and
you people don't understand and you
can't plant your foot
boys what do you guys think do you think
this entices john for one more fight
to come back and instead tweet us off he
put a tool like that
he was being messy he was being
is they probably want to set up for him
versus the ocean but the ocean
understanding needs more time he's not
ready and i
don't think they want to put him versus
inganu
if it's yeah
so shout out to john you know shout out
to poland of the bill the first polish
champion
i thought that was dope you know he was
very happy let's get to that music
i wrote them all down okay we have the
black prodigy with the five dollar super
chat
yo guys can you imagine e3 next year
sony would have to back out bro would be
a massacre
we gonna get to that here in a minute
man we will get you right here
then it's sunday people shout out to the
best of the best podcast on sunday thank
you my brother
looking forward to hearing king
untethered yeah
it's arguable that king is always
untethered
today is a special day let's say that
you know how cognito always tries to be
in the middle
he can't be in the middle he got an xbox
shirt on
look at that
speculation here
vacationing in washington he feels the
need to come the next day
with the with the x-box
with the name start with the p and end
with a s uh
uh king 221 the imminent destruction of
pony nation we just
we're adding scripture every day every
day to the book of eggs
and we have handled humble beast again
with king 221 the okay he did it twice
oh i did it twice um squirrely dan with
the two dollar super chat
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
just wait till we swap out that other
music that's that's when it's really
gonna get jumping
and we got smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat anyone got a problem
with
the book of acts talk to me in color no
i sent talk oh my god wow
that's a fact though he just he just
shut you down if you're not putting your
numbers done
you know what i've noticed these xbox
fans put put their money where they
mouth is they
they are confident in their words oh my
god
not not for nothing due to phil dominus
maximus aurelia spencer
he has allowed them to save tons of
money with game pass so they don't
understand actually is that how they're
going to start doing those commercials
for game pass do you want to do more
super chats
subscribe to game pass and save money
we got the wise old gamer with the five
dollar super chat phil the jim ryan and
his young ralph voice
if you see me in the club pull a dime up
then i'm walking to the ball with your
main girl like that
keep keep my please give this ponies
hell on the on guarding them all hell
xbox crowd is good the round is rowdy
rowdy this week to be expected
but why would they be rowdy nothing
happened absolutely
as i said i have no idea why we're here
today because it was a very boring
weekend
very low at low news
again uh what the hell oh hold on i
gotta move this over
memphis and king give them hell oh there
you go there you go
then we have as we cheat with the five
dollars which diego has to retire reyes
was too cautious
and costa weighed it's way too much to
save gas and got a clinic from izzy and
that's the thing still been the style
hard
um yeah yo costa even even though he was
holding back
he was winded because izzy was kicking
the air out of him so we'll
let's get in let's get into this this
fight yeah i'll hold this super car
no no oh you want one more or should we
get into it
let me see hold after taz which we have
smitty smith
smith super uh super christmas smitty
smith laura carney is looking refreshed
enjoy your well-deserved vacation
actually so very quiet
then we have nelson
you guys think that skyrim should be the
new face of xbox instead of
oh they're going there that's actually a
real question
i don't know do you guys think luna is
going to even compete with it and we're
going to get to that
all right so you're going to talk about
that card because i didn't put that in
the in the title because i was talking
about that oh it's fine look i'll make
it real quick man shout out to style
i mean at the end of the day coming into
this fight
you know benji specifically i was
nervous for not
just because i know costa's style and he
let's be real
you know i know skill will win but at
the end of the day that's a big boy
the weight the amount of weight he cuts
to make that division
is absurd so i looked at that fight
that's okay if izzy's
if he has uh yo yo what's his romero
performance
like it might not go well for you know i
mean so i was looking at that
and it just come to show like the
precision the style
the confidence and then just chipping
away the leg kick slowly
breaking the boy down picking them apart
and it just shows
his striking is on another level it's
not even close and you know all that
basic
rush tactics that i thought would
effects now been that
it it was almost an easy fight
oh yeah it was yeah it didn't manifest
itself at all
yeah it didn't manifest itself to me now
it's like the sky's the limit
you know he's going to clean that
division now first of all let's just get
straight to the funny stuff though
what was up with the disrespect after
the war
yes all right so the build up to the
fight and then the the background
because i was looking at a lot of the
background stuff
yeah because i was actually paying for
that content um
a lot of the background stuff and i i
don't say this to say that he is racist
i don't know but
a lot of times uh lightest skin
brazilians are a little bit uh
they they treat the darker skin
brazilians a little bit
you know worth aware to be honest with
you right man
it happens everywhere all right to each
other as well which is disgusting but
yeah because a lot of a lot of my puerto
rican
uh heritage are my color um so
leading up to that it was like a little
racial undertone to it and then he was
real dismissive
of him and he was being real cocky and
real arrogant
costa was in his stance towards uh oh my
god here we go
that's for me to get up now for the uh
so um and and then
he had to disrespect him in the form
because he felt disrespected the whole
fight
to keep his emotions in check the way he
did
i commend the hell out of him because he
kept to his game plan and costa kept
trying to get him to open that shell yes
did you see how his leg his leg looked
like my shirt
at the end
was and it's i'm glad there's no crowd
so you can
really hear the impact every time he got
hit yeah he he was setting them up
beautifully
like that the undertones under the fight
they were definitely there also
there were a lot of skinny kid
undertones like you know
yes small guy like and you know for
people who don't watch
mixed martial arts and i'll give it to
you is that you know
a lot of times you look physically at
these athletes and you're like if you
don't know anything about the sport
you'll go whoa how is this guy even
going to compete with this guy
right and and that's the beauty of mixed
martial arts right
all that muscle and all that weight it
don't mean nothing
if you don't have technique you know
what i'm saying and you don't have
discipline so i just thought it was a
massive
fight for him it definitely cemented him
now as one of the top middleweights
he's you know the sky's limited i think
he wants to fight uh what's the cannon
here whatever
you know possibly clean out division and
then there's still a super fight with
jones that he's interested in
then he's even alluding the heavyweight
so he's in the driver's seat i'll give
it the prince what did you think i saw a
couple of your tweets
like what did you think about it yeah i
mean it was an
absolute master class i mean it was just
it wasn't even close at any point there
was no point of that fight that was and
i'll tell you what leading up to it
i was picking israel to win but i
thought it was going to be like a
a fourth or fifth round i think this
fight was going to go late because
i thought the early rounds costa might
really pressure and give him a little
trouble
i didn't think cosa was going to win but
i thought i thought if you're gonna beat
izzy you gotta get in on him you cannot
be at that range because he will just
pick you apart but shout out to izzy he
he just
could not be cornered the few times that
costa did try to rush him he was just
out instantly and uh yeah he just
lit him up it was it was one of the best
performances i've seen in a long time it
was
incredible yeah absolutely like benji
said it was a master class it was
it's what i love to see in mma when you
have a dude that
is kind of like like jones like jones
will take your own style and use it
against you to show you that he's better
than you
all right izzy doesn't necessarily do
that izzy just
knows that he's better than you and he's
going to beat you he's going to beat you
any which way
he's going to do it whether it's
distance and you know i'm sure that his
ground game
and and his grapple game is is
definitely underrated
he never has to use it um i just want to
say this one thing and
then i'll jump out of that part with it
um
he knows who was great before him
yes and he has studied
all different styles because one
he came into listening to nas all right
so
when when i'm talking about he's
studying greatness
he's studying greatness he choreographs
his entry in his head
and his soul and his body when he gets
into the ring when he does this stuff
right here and y'all probably think he's
joking around
he's channeling his chi right and he is
getting to his
center so when he comes in listening to
nas that's his inspiration music because
he has to live up to the greatness of
this song right and
then he already knows that anderson
silva was
the greatest before him and he's trying
to surpass
that greatness right yeah yeah also
at the end if y'all didn't catch it he
told you you must have forgot like the
great
yeah right so
when roy was disrespected in that fight
that he so-called lost
and roy came in you know any time roy
was disrespected he
put on a performance that was worthy so
this
man went in with all these greats in him
to give you this great performance
he broke down costa in a way that costa
looked bewildered at that
like who the hell is this dude but the
biggest thing was
he told dana and he put it on air
no more 30 percent yeah i like that
90 if they don't make this weight
because
costa didn't feel like he had to make
weight and and
and he thought he was going to have an
advantage weight-wise going in because
these dudes use that they have other uh
things outside the ring to supplant that
money so if they lose a 30 grand here
they have a nike deal or t-shirt deal
here or there to give them that extra
money so they don't care about making
weight
so when you take 90 percent of their
purse away then they will start taking
it seriously
and i really respected him for that give
him they give him an hour and a half
to try to make weight afterwards yes
that's yeah that's correct yeah even if
you miss they still give you an extra
hour and a half shout out to kobic nexus
i'm calling todd let's let's just
all right let's get these super chats
and
move on all right is that
what he made a good point after the
after match i didn't realize
100 fights and that
you forget he is a kickboxer he's been
doing this for a long time
you know i mean so i just wanted to give
that out there as far as the length of
experience that he has he's really
not as young in the game as we think he
is but salute to izzy
master class performance and i'll let
y'all get to it because
i don't want to talk about this no more
all right we have adam with the five
dollars of a chat xbox didn't spend 7.5
billion dollars to try and give up on
their console
if their plan was full multi-plat they
wouldn't have made two consoles
facts we will talk about that and we
have perfect shogun with the 20
super chat and elder scrolls uh through
wolfenstein after the fallout phil
dominus maximus aurelia spencer says
your rage has dishonored you turn from
the evil within pray on the like button
and be spared
poetry poetry in the chat jesus
then we have lonzo with the five
thousand chat costa left the girl he
came to the dance with
aggression and pressure brought him
success and he abandoned it in the
biggest fight of his career
because he was afraid of getting dropped
in two seconds that's why
he would have run in and izzy would have
pulled the conor mcgregor yeah he
got blasted yeah it would have been but
it would have been a problem
with the five dollar super chat happens
is most of latin america
have it in my family too it's sad
hopefully we'll come together soon we're
on the same boat yeah like i said like
it is very disgusting like the way
and it's not everyone but it happens a
lot where lighters lighter skinned
latinos will
will treat dark-skinned latinos like
they're not they don't come from the
same place and it's like really
like so everybody is in between how you
figure they got in between
like everybody that's round like me like
everybody's down around me somebody in
my family is very dark
exactly it's it's it's a sad thing it's
you know but it it shows the state of
the world unfortunately
then we have bravo with the five dollar
super chat when do you think microsoft
kicks the tires on possibly giving halo
over to its software
shout out to benzie that is a very
interesting question to have yes
yes uh conversation to have i told y'all
anyway but y'all didn't listen to me
i told you potential
become discussed and i told you they
always had this potential they can never
get this part right or they can get that
part right
well obviously now you have first-person
gods in the house
so when are you going to live for god
so that's that we have one more somebody
said for the five dollars israel bro don
costa like someone trying to get the
crab meat out the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow these analogies are wow
quite vividly before we get the car
let's go to the lord benji
benji what you been up to man oh not a
lot
of flow news week what can i say
i respect that you're going along with
the inside joke i respect that
no no i've been trying to keep up with
the insanity the last week or two it's
like
it almost feels like we can barely sleep
right now because a brand new crazy
story is gonna drop every you know six
hours it's been crazy but
outside of that just playing games going
to work doing my twitter youtube thing
you know
okay thank you i have to say i have to
say i i had voted to never have you on
again after
after that after the final finale see
slander last time i was like no i can't
have
it and then obviously i got out voted so
thank goodness hey they thanks the rest
of the crew to have in my back
yeah we got you guys don't pay attention
we love you sir
how are you
what's going on listen man it's been
absolutely fantastic being out here i
mean
washington great state great people i
want to make a couple shout outs
obviously
down to the great wall bill stillwell
himself got a chance to talk with that
brother oh man the stories
just good times good guy
he says his love goes to the whole realm
you know we can talk tech for hours
it's just great to see him moving on in
his next endeavors
tremendous stuff obviously you know
what's going on in the industry which
we'll talk about
these topics nothing's going on remember
no that's true they didn't slow me you
are correct
so um and then i also want to shout out
shout out to colt eastwood on the rdx
podcast man got a chance to chop it up
and finally meet him more than five
minutes remember
they vipped us that e3 that year yeah we
had to do the we had to do the roll away
we had to like
wave our king and colt were in the vip
section of
the conference and addicts were being
shooed along with the commoners
i was right there with you guys
it was like 100 degrees out there and
they had a canopy for them
and and we're baking
and mind you all of us all of us are
hung over all of us
i said i said excuse me man i have some
perrier please
yeah they were they were passing the
palapa also kingsley can i get some
orange juice jelly okay
king's like can i get some orange juice
for my commonwealth friend here
thank you to the grace the graciousness
of king for noticing
us
remember security
good food good drinks also shout out to
um bill stilwell for putting me on the
fried pickles
those are amazing
when we went to have dinner on and you
didn't have any of them
i put you on the fried pickles long long
time ago when weeds all tim dog me you
megatron lemon
i know i said you said what is it what
should i get i said make sure you get
the fried pickles you looked at me and
was like the hell i'm doing
i had that but also the last but not
least shout out to uh richard fogey
amazing time you know probably at undead
labs stuff like that
really got a chance to talk life to that
brother really good guy he's got a lot
of stuff going on i can't wait to
discuss
at a date when he's ready but um yeah
man a lot of people shout out to
you know redmond campus and jason ronald
and
a lot of those guys yeah look at this
shirt somebody had an optimize
first off that's an e3 shirt that's an
e3 shirt
it was a lot of microsoft money shirts
no no i was joking you're trying to make
it seem like we sold out stop it
i mean i know i know for a fact the iron
bank has not uh
spent any money on uh travel expenses
let me tell you something man uh
something
you know next thing you know he's going
to tell us he has that exact same phone
they're sending out for the x clouds
it's great but definitely miss you guys
definitely can't wait to go back and be
back home
she said i'm gonna need that restaurant
list i got you um stacks is one of them
uh amazing stack 571 hollywood tavern
and then i'll give you another one that
was really really good oh and shout out
to oh
addict shout out to jansen shout out to
jason for pulling up
addicts one of alex friends xbox box
live party member
we used to beef with like i used to beef
with this kid
used to be like it used to be one of
those things where i couldn't have them
both in the same party yeah i would have
to manage who i'm in a party well
it was about psych i was like i don't
like him like i really get into
it with people back in the day but i
used to get into with this kid
and just to see his transformation and
my transformation and just how he
in the flesh yo how you doing how are
you doing you want to eat you want to t
that was another spot we went to bed
good times and just kept
hanging out there i'm really pumped
all right let's get these super chats
real quick we have a shasmati with the
five dollar super chat
sony to bethesda used to be my homie now
you act like you don't know me then we
have
enzo with the five dollar super chat
looking forward to all the bethesda
games coming exclusively to xbox
um we'll talk about that sir uh michael
aka best that's fine it's five dollar
super chat
ponies can't make their mind up now they
want xbox exclusives to come to ps to
playstation lord these guys are nuts
right from stickers in the flesh and
said time
the lord king was in the canopy with the
grey poupon
i think that is it all right so for me
real quick we'll round out
um this week i finally got to play a
little something oh we gotta say thank
you to
whatever who gave us the five dollars
but you had to be deleted
oh no no he read it i read that i don't
know why
smoove deleted that it must have been
something a little bit
flagrant no it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't
i was i was going to pull kid's side
after after the show would ask why you
deleted that
okay so then tell him to put it inside
the chat so we can read it no he read it
he read it
already
real quick mexican zoidberg with the
five dollar super chat the day king
stops making fun of tcl's
the day of the world
i got some tcl smoke today so y'all like
the only thing i played this week it is
the new crack
if you guys have not heard how i spoke
about
dead cells this is how i feel about this
game
hades yo
oh haiti yeah yeah fire fighter i've
heard good things i haven't played if i
heard it's amazing
i downloaded for switch for the playing
back but you're talking
bro it has that it has that loop
where it's like it has the super giant
storytelling
um it's probably the most polished game
and in terms of story
it plays it's basically uh what you call
roguelike
um where you're constantly you're you're
the son of hades and you're trying to
escape the underworld because you're
like yo
i i didn't i never died like i was born
here i want to get out of here
and so the other gods in olympus sort of
they hear about your plight and they try
to help you
by giving you powers and whatnot to try
to allow you to
escape uh the underworld so that's the
loop that's the
in a gameplay that i really haven't seen
a game like this do before you can't
it's really hard to do an
uh a consistent narrative in a game
where the gameplay loop is
is individual runs um but it's
like the the voice acting the
storytelling the gameplay
it's just tight man it is if you love
dead cells
and again it looks differently it plays
differently but it's that same feeling
like
one more run one more run one more it is
a fantastic game
uh why it's right all of a sudden out of
nowhere it
it's up there in my top couple of games
of the year wow
it is that great so that's what i did um
let's get to
it let's get to the main event of the
evening and then you know the iron lords
podcast the main event always comes
first
and then we have to rush through the
rest because it was so long
on the topic it's already on oh my man
there we go
there you go there you go so um
gentlemen
on monday one day before pre-orders went
up for the xbox series x and s
early in the morning we got a little
message from our friends at xbox
welcoming the fine folks from zenimax
and bethesda
into the xbox family um
all i could say throughout the entire
day was yo
yo yo
so
we'll start with benji first benji i
this is what this is what i want to get
from everybody
what were your initial reactions like
immediately
where were you when you heard that
that's going to be where were you when
this happened
the biggest purchase and gave me history
i want to frame it with another thing
too and it's in the sense of
you know obviously announcement and then
we have okay
but there's the the xbox tweets out but
that's there's an incredibly talented
studio over 2200 people
and then they show these other people
worldwide and make up the studios
it's bethesda studios in software
xenomax online
arcane studios machine games tango game
works and
alpha dog games and roundhouse studios
and then for clarity xbox continues to
tweet
you know these amazing teams are
responsible for iconic franchises like
the elder scrolls the elder scrolls
online
fallout wolfenstein dude dishonored
evil within prey quake
and starfield so this is the information
that's like hitting us so i'll give it
back to you so
yeah give it to me you're right i think
i think i think
everybody's get is used to just calling
them bethesda right yes
don't stop and think about what that
what that signifies until
later on in like the post you're like
wait a minute they just upped their
the studio count from 15 to 23 in one
fell swoop
that is that's kind of bonkers so again
benji
what did you feel when you first heard
about it what were your feelings as
as you sort of absorb the information
later on and and what do you think this
means moving forward
yeah so for me i literally woke up in
bed
i look at my phone because like a lot of
people it's the first thing i do in the
morning
unfortunately i look at i look at my
phone and
literally the first thing i see i hit
twitter
and just everywhere i'm seeing xbox
bethesda xbox
and i'm like at first i'm not believing
it i'm like there's no way
what like we're starting off the morning
where xbox has acquired bethesda
so it took a couple minutes for it to
truly process what was going on
and uh the price i mean 7.5 billion
dollars you see something like that and
you're like my goodness it's the second
biggest
purchase like dollar wise ever in the
gaming industry
the only one bigger than this was uh 10
cent buying supercell which was
8 billion but this is the second biggest
of all time
and it's the first time microsoft bought
a publisher right we'd see that
right we'd seen them by developers we'd
seen them by people that
i would say weren't some of them were
surprises but some of them weren't like
playground you know when we got an
announcement like that's like
makes sense though was a whole nother
level
so you know my my first thoughts were oh
my goodness like
the fact it was all of zenimax like it's
not just they poached one studio away
they got you know one or two like it's
all of them like you said now we're up
to
23 studios it's completely insane
i mean it makes sense it's a giant price
tag but i think it completely makes
sense with the strategy with game pass
moving forward
i i'm guessing we're going to go into
the whole exclusivity talks later
yeah um so i'll wait to talk about that
because
i have a lot of opinions on that but uh
yeah that was just some of my kind of
initial thoughts whenever i saw it go
down was wow this is
this is a different level than anything
we'd seen before
absolutely absolutely so let's go with
attic next because addict
addict was in our chat i don't know if
alex was sleeping at the time
yeah i woke up so let's see what's funny
is okay i woke up
actually i was sleeping in the living
room at that time because while my mom
stays here she sleeps in my room so i'm
sitting there
i wake up my my phone's dead at this
time so i go
i get up i charge it and then i'm
sitting there looking at and then the
first thing i see is kid smoothie he
sends me a tweet and says i need a
thumbnail
now and i'm sitting there looking at i
don't click the tweet
i go straight to my room because i'm
like i need to make this thumbnail so i
sit down
i pull up twitter i go up there and i
look and i was like
and then i see people constantly
tweeting like you know
most of the time i get like you know the
20 plus notification thing on twitter
when i wake up
but this was different because i clicked
it and i unclicked it got something to
drink came back
it was it was there again so so i'm
saying i'm like what is going on
and i see cognito keeps tweeting me in
this uh
this thing from obsidian that has
obsidian making like the gif sound like
this
looking at it and at first when i read
it i was like
they don't own that they can't do why is
people tagging me in this
so sitting there and then i go back to
i'm okay let me make the kids move
this is like 10 minutes being up all
right so i'm like okay let me go ahead
and go to twitter and make this
thumbnail so i click on the messages i
click on the actual tweet this time
that kids sent me and then i kid you not
i went like this
i was like oh my god i'm sitting there
i say it like five times my mom's behind
me she's like oh is something wrong is
something wrong i'm like
that has nothing to do with you i was
like i'm sitting here like i'm in shock
like i'm in straight up shock because
people need to realize
this is something when it's brought up
we talk about it for five minutes to be
like
yeah but you know that's impossible
that's never gonna happen and we just
keep it moving
this is one of those topics on a podcast
you don't even talk about because it's
so absurd
and to notice that it happens i'm just
like
it's like hit me like left and right i
was okay they bought but that's the
i was like did that mean that they only
owned skyr and then and then and then i
see that thing that phil spencer
posted all them i was like they all
dishonored like
i'm sitting there like i'm getting hit
with so much like
i was literally speechless i had
nothing to say well first thing i did is
like i want to see the world burn let me
go
let me go check out twitter i literally
said i sat at my room just doing this
for like 30 minutes
i agree i agree that's kind of
the reaction like let me go next because
i want to set up cog and king
let's go wait was that so i was again i
was at work
as i as i tend to be and i was like
right before cog posted it in our chat
i saw it so i didn't even get a chance
to put it in the chat yo
so i saw a cog quitting yo i'm hearing
that they bought bethesda
and i'm like it's true it's true
again like i said i was literally just
saying yo the whole day like
this is a bigger power move as i have
ever seen
dude they they removed an e3 press
conference off the table
this is equivalent to you going to e3
and you're watching one of these
conferences
and it's like microsoft was watching an
old press conference
just go ahead and call them just buy the
whole thing we want all of that they
better let bethesda be bethesda man they
better let them make that yeah
we got to talk about the aftermath yeah
my favorite press conference
right there don't mess with that that is
kind of true
shout out to 600 people in the chat man
hit that like button if you guys don't
mind let's try to get that up right this
is
everybody came for the smoke today
i i got a lot of messy followers
so you know this when i stopped to think
for a second this is still kind of
my reaction when you've been following
microsoft like all of us here have from
the very beginning when they entered the
gaming space
right it was always strange to me that a
company that's this big and powerful
was playing the underdog role in the
gaming space
and it's always been that way and it's
just because of the the attachment
people have to the sony brand and
rightfully so
and even you know 20 years on it's still
kind of the same way
but it if you look at the moves that
they've made up until now
none of them compares to this you know
we made jokes in the chat about you know
putting the meat on the table
this is they made a move that their
competitor can't do
correct they just can't what's the money
someone put in the chat they said
microsoft literally spent what sony made
last year
in price their whole budget they spit on
one company
somebody somebody's a little slush fun
i'm gonna get it dirty dude
it really is uh indicative of a yet
again like another sort of paradigm
shift and we'll talk about the details
about that in a minute but
let's go to [ __ ] next yeah i mean this
is
man these are as a gamer they're moments
right they're moments like where were
you
when this happened when were you when
this system announced when you were this
major
like this is beyond just you know a
smaller
individual acquisition you know when you
buy
bethesda the thing that's great about
this is two for one
we all know bethesda's history you know
what i'm saying as far as those quality
epic single player for the most part
experiences
and they just have a cache they kick me
you know like we go to those bethesda
conferences
boys are not suits these are gamers
right
we have a passion for this all right and
there's this level of quality and i wish
anchorman was here today actually
because
he's the biggest
you know people don't know this about me
but i used to be a huge bethesda fan boy
like absurd and like i'm a huge fan of
todd howard
not maybe not quite as bad as anchorman
but you know
i remember like when that that uh
video showed up afterwards the video
interview with major nelson phil spencer
peter
peter and um and todd howard and i
remember thinking
this is real like like because
i remember like watching the skyrim and
now uh trailers and todd howard is like
with gamestop he's like this is a dragon
like and i remember that
resonating with me and i'm like and i
think todd howard's part of microsoft
now
like that's crazy
it's one of those moments it's you you
sit back and you say wait a minute did
that
just happen is is is the entire
cinematic all of these students and then
it starts you start to think of the
major stuff first right
you start to think of elder scrolls then
you're like wait a minute microsoft owns
doom now
he was one of the first calls one of the
first calls
you know and then like cog it just went
down and for me the immediate feeling i
felt solved was like
we all sat there last generation and
said okay
can are they truly going to commit
is microsoft really good no disrespect
to any studio they've purchased right
now
but we also if game pass is going to be
the play
the the achilles heel so to speak was
triple a quality games in the service
and no disrespect to microsoft's current
first party
but that was the argument used against
it like if i'm gonna get game pass i
don't want
filler and i don't want all indie games
i want so if you look at
what they've acquired you start making
scenarios in your head theoretically
right like they could have bangers just
line up lined up like literally and you
know the cool
one like literally like one more you
know the crazy thing if you think about
it man
it's like we're sitting here we've been
talking about bethesda for like
two weeks it feels like and it's like we
forgot about the initiative
we forgot about compulsion we forgot
about undead labs like
it's like it's like it's like i said
last week they could
but that does studios could literally
like
pull a whole console into existence like
let's say amazon comes out they're like
let's buy bethesda their games could
keep their console afloat
microsoft has that and their actual
games the thing about it is you know how
much of an obsidian fan boy i
am so i'm like wait a minute they could
work together
did you start thinking we didn't make
fallout new vegas
and halo together like you you can have
these out
it almost felt like if you're a sports
team like
like uh this huge free agent position
and you're like yo this is all on one
team like this is a dream team so to
speak
so it's just like i said it was really
cool you start thinking of possibilities
you start thinking about the commitment
to gaming and it it was truly amazing
and like i said
it's one of those situations we'll get
into exclusively we'll get to all that
stuff in a minute
but it's one of those situations where
the first the second thought i had
was i got to speak the king
what was i still asleep at this time you
were still asleep you were like okay you
got
we all know it the name phil dominance
maximus
kate gave him a really good last week
two weeks ago right
right but then i'm like when i see this
level of a move
i know who my guy is right i'm a peter
moore guy i've always been a sega kid
i i felt that generation was one of the
glory generations
for xbox but i'm sitting there i i have
to admit
i couldn't think of a move a single move
with one fell swoop someone swung their
sword
and it's like yes
yeah i felt the same way because it was
like yo you know the peter moore pulled
up the sleeve
gta 4 move like i remember yeah peter
would pull speed up gta exclusive
a singular title which was epic for its
time or it's time for sure
nothing to dis magazine he didn't go by
rockstar
and it pains me to say it because i'm
such a
from peterborough but i gotta give it to
my big kick right now
i'm gonna talk like let's let's get into
it man
we have the laurels we have the toga
let's go
and i've officially clicked on your name
you have the floor
i was uh y'all want to get the super
chats um as a matter of fact yes
let's do that before we get the king as
a matter of fact first off let's welcome
to the realm lord jerrell johnson
welcome stern thank you for the probably
a relative of mine
and hold on let me get back to it yeah
we have smitty smith i believe
right he's yeah somebody smith for the
final author chat microsoft pulled off
some galactic power move-ish yes this is
very thano-ish
this is very in that room then we have
pixel bit g with the two dollar super
chat play with the bull get the horns
hashtag the book of acts new scripture
every day
then we have a humble beast with the ten
dollar ship chat do you know
what rhymes with pony station nation
logical fallacy citation cognitive
dissonance solicitation
inbred transmutation representation oh
my god wow
brain degradation ingrained vegetarian
ps exclusive wow that's going on that's
crazy
yeah oh somebody somebody's drinking
early
then we have lord t moore with the two
two pounds of attack
ea was the one uh max thoughts
uh
thanks thanks for having me i like work
shorty
okay we have a dissenting opinion here
with thomas here with the photographer
if y'all keep up with king's damage
control thrash
he needs to be broken down and taking
the task fanboy isn't embodied
okay i just want you to stick around so
i can lash you around
thank you thank you though i really you
know what i really appreciate it because
we welcome everybody's opinion for sure
and at no point
we're gonna suppress what you're gonna
say and you can agree with me or you
don't have to agree with me
you know sometimes you can walk in the
light and sometimes you can stay in the
dark
but right now i'm gonna shine some light
on you i can't do it
all over as long as everybody keeps it
respectful we don't yeah
i love that i love you what you got to
say we love it all we love it all
um we got forte with the 2000 chat i was
wiping the code from my eye when i saw
it
yeah earlier then we have best size
finances to follow up with chat
microsoft spend 75 billion dollars so
many fans don't realize that they spent
more money than
than what sony profits in the year on
god and them outside
of the day we spend what you had in your
bank account
they made the move that their opponent
just can't make they can't follow you
there they can't they just can't they
can't climb that mountain shout out to
the egyptians let me get some
yeah i was this close to buying bethesda
tonight and beat me to the bunch
but i have that
yeah i got that first i got it before uh
we have clutch man with the five dollar
super chat
didn't mikey barra join bethesda if so
does that mean he works for microsoft
again
blizzard you know how crazy i would be
if you leave michael's often they buy
yours hilarious
a couple more we have kids move with the
20 super chat
xbox buy zen and max bethesda and all
its studios ips etc playstation is
actively keeping
uh third-party games off of xbox thus
keeping them off of game pass and xbox
is expected to put first party games on
the playstation
because of goodwill we will talk about
that
matter of fact kiss move has a hell of a
video up please go check out that video
after this
yes sir so then we have a seafood sifu
poetic
initiative with the five dollar super
attack this is a move to get ready for
war
i'm sure your third topic will cover
those uh other giants that that are set
to announce major moves in 2021
um and i think we're all caught up so i
just set up the king like that
that was my thing like you know he was
the first person that came to my mind
and again he has been instilling the
phil
dominance max with spencer narrative for
a long time
you know what's funny people would
always be like is king gonna be the knee
or you know in past experiences like no
he's just gonna double down that's what
i've said every time he's gonna double
down that was the first one because his
faith in this man has been unwavering
even when i you know it's one of those
like transformers like
light our darkness it was the darkest
hour
last generation so king before it's
yours
let's get the super chat to clear this
oh
no no no this is an important super chat
all right
uh we got to fight off from the ill
rollers he said dude was talking about
king thrash punctuation was off
he wasn't talking about king he's
talking about okay sorry about that
that's why i wanted to get that
before king went in on that yeah i
wasn't gonna go in on him personally you
you spend your money you was actually
he wasn't being rude or anything like
that so i'm not going in on you like
that that's not gonna happen
um you just have a different amount of
opinion but i
thank you for clearing that up i do
appreciate that and you could just put
it in the chat also sometimes you don't
have to clear something up by spending
extra money just to clear it up because
we'll see it if you just at one of us
you know
um because listen i i understand um
i was jogging i was in my eighth or
ninth uh
a mile at this time and my
phone was going bananas i got a text
first that said oh my god from blue
so i'm like and then i um i have the
headphones on
and i pick up the phone call boom it's
like oh my god
oh my god he did it he did it he's a
realist you're right
you're a writer what are you talking
about
microsoft more bethesda
[Laughter]
like a japanese movie like yeah
so i'm like what he's like yes
yes you are told you oh my god
dude you will not be dude right so i'm
like calm down
boom talk to me man he's like yeah they
brought them for seven point something
billion
oh go go check it out all right so i'm
jogging
this is the hardest last five or four
miles that i had left
because i you know i do the 13 so i'm
i'm reading it as i'm jogging i'm like
yo that's my guy
yes i said this i said you know i got
laughed at
when i gave him dominus i gave i got
laughed at when i gave him a maximus
and and i got laughed at when i said
soon to be a really is everybody's like
soon to be irrelevant
yeah i remember that
they i i mean you know i had people that
i never
met on podcast that had a level of
vitriol
for me because of my fandom
towards microsoft right um
and i know fan is short for fanatic and
sometimes it may seem like oh this guy
how are you gonna call another man
dominus i said his moves is dominating
his moves is maximus his moves are
maximus aurelius is golden
so that move is golden when i told you
that he was going to put them in the
kill box
see what it is it's very different when
you're an individual given all the tools
right but when you're given limited
tools limited resources
and you have people actively
trying to destroy you from within your
own company
and you have to navigate that to succeed
what's that whole line how to move in
the room full of schools
snakes without getting bit i'll get bit
let's talk about it
terry myerson don matrix talk about it
king
the man was a literal worker
and ascended to the highest of
i guess and this is probably not his
highest aspiration see
when y'all didn't understand why i
gravitated towards him why i picked him
when i spoke to him
he exudes something that i have inside
of myself
a unsatiated hunger to achieve
and only real can recognize real
so if you looked at him and you thought
he was fake then you were seeing
something else
you've seen a reflection of yourself in
something else
but when i saw him i said oh he's the
real deal
um that's a lot of people not to cut
your king but a lot of people even
myself but i i got a better need of you
on this is that
we all love phil right we think he's
great for the job but i think the issue
that i i needed to see was the killing
i'm addressing here okay this was
something different
shout out to grime i guess because
you've never been back
um you put me to task
and you yell oh they putting halo inside
of pachinko boxes and all this goofy
stuff that you was going on with
and oh phil is too nice how nice is he
now
i told you he's not nice but see there's
a different level of tact and level of
sophistication that you must exude
when you're making your moves you must
build
allies instead of building dissension so
you want him to run inside the room and
tear everything up
where he can actually get allies to help
him turn the crowd
in your favor to move as a team in a
unit
and remove the individuals that aren't
worthy
did you notice that after certain
individuals was removed from key
spots he ascended faster he's at the
table
he's at the table for sure now the
purchase
yeah let's get it i told y'all that had
they had studios that was coming
did not know about this heard about this
before right
so i'm hearing about the little ones
that they're talking about i heard about
those things
this fits every need in one swing of the
sword
facts and this is overpaying
okay because they weren't worth
7.6 billion dollars
that's the equivalent of you going
through a drive-through
you're getting a burger and some fries
it comes up to nine dollars ten dollars
and you give them a 20
billion say keep the change
that means you don't want anything wrong
with your mail
that means that you just want to get
your stuff and go
and you even being there is a hindrance
on your soul
do you understand when they went into
the room they probably said okay well
we're at 4 billion
7.6 is that enough
that is enough is that enough to get
this done because i got a boat that i
got to be on
yeah there was there was multiple
bidders going on at once for this
and they shut them all down yeah because
they said oh
that that's too rich for my blood they
did this right before preordering
these things you see in the auctions
where you know uh they're voting and
someone comes out there and
someone's like 500 15 000.
and that's it you shut it down you get
what you want you get what you want and
you need
all right so
the acquisition is not bethesda stop
saying bethesda they brought the
building
they didn't go in there and brought uh
buy one
shirt one t-shirt a pair of pants and
some uh
socks they didn't go get an outfit
they went and brought them all they shut
down the mall and said they said what do
you want i want everything
i want the light fishes i want the
foundations i want the urinals
i want it oh and said i want the yard
and i'm blocking it off from everybody
else and this is for my peoples only
so so if they don't have this idea
walking in the in
the door they ain't for them so
when i told you he was going to do this
to you
stop poking the bear stop making
microsoft be microsoft well this is
microsoft being microsoft and phil
dominance maximus so really a spencer
has done it to you
now we're going to get into the other
stuff you'll get to other stuff and the
thing two ways
i want to add on is that to make it it's
kind of funny because it's like
last generation you know the the
infamous me
we all know right you know benji's heard
it everyone
you know when it comes to microsoft you
know great hardware company
but no games right that's the the
infamous meme and it's just so funny in
one fell swoop where did we go we went
from what is it thirteen turn the arby's
is going to be exclusive i do have one
question for you guys
uh i want to start with benji do you
think that sony has to react to this
not like not necessarily oh we need to
buy something right now
but do you think this purchase people
over sony's like okay
we gotta buy something what they're
ready we got we gotta increase our
studio count because
like to me like especially since i
bought bethesda i feel like you're going
to get to a point
where the quality and quantity of
microsoft is going to surpass
sony if they keep up with the output
that they have right now
before i get with the betty two is
didn't saturn they're still not
done oh they're not gonna all right yeah
but couldn't take that baby i'm curious
yeah so so to not go to insider info
here sony
shopping yeah there are studios they are
currently talking to
and have been talking to um so the
answer
the short answer is yes they do need to
respond
um but it is something that they are
actually
right now currently trying to do right
now we are in a seller's market there
are a lot of studios that are going to
be acquired over the next five years
um all across the board microsoft's
buying more sony's buying more
will not be surprised if you see amazon
at google by some people
so yeah we're in consolidation phase
right now for the gaming industry
um doesn't mean like everyone's going to
be bought i see some people like
panicking like oh my goodness there's
there's going to be no one it's going to
three companies
no don't worry it's not gonna be like
that uh we still are gonna have tons of
massive publishers there's gonna be a
lot of indy there's gonna be a lot of
variety
but you know we are in the middle of the
consolidation phase right now i see a
lot of people talk about like
oh is that something in the future like
no it's happening right now microsoft by
themselves have acquired so many
you have to remember the insomniac
purchase was not really that long ago in
terms of
like we're in the middle of it right now
and it's not ending
anytime soon so if i was sony i
definitely would swoop in
and lock down those partners
that you have a relationship with i
would be securing kojima productions i
would be securing blue point i would be
veering house mark like these companies
i would lock down because here's the
thing
if you don't you do run the risk that
someone else
is going with you there's a lot not even
necessarily microsoft though
yeah exactly there's there's some big
companies entering the gaming space
right now
with a lot of money so i see it as one
of those things like not like a panic
vibe but like
securing like hey we have a good
relationship just like what happened
with insomniac we're gonna lock you down
just to make sure someone else can't
come in with a seven billion dollar
paycheck
and buy you out so that's the thing i
think that's why
that's why this type of acquisition can
happen right now because like you said
the the space is getting more and more
crowded whether it's with actual
consoles whether it's cloud and we'll
talk about iran
a little bit it's the gaming space
period is getting super crowded
and you have all these companies have to
look for differentiators
differentiators for their product so
you're gonna see amazon purchasing
you're gonna see stadia purchasing
and it's like the big three in in in
traditional gaming
have to be careful because even i think
it's even more protecting from that than
protecting from themselves right
um i know phil has always really been
about you know oh kumbaya we're all
working together this time
obviously this move says something
somewhat different but
um but at the same time i do think that
when they look at
the impending sort of uh attack from
amazon and google you do have to sort of
say hey we have to protect this space
that we're in well
i mean you could say he says but if he
doesn't look at you as a threat
you can play fun and games with your
little kid brother
you know oh my god he looked at an
antenna and
you laughed at him before like what
you're not looking at that's his
competition no
if he's spending your whole budget in in
a burgers
deal get out of here like you really
don't really understand what he did
you're not a threat it wasn't hyperbole
when he when he
when he said like we're not in
competition with them
it really wasn't and and the crazy thing
about it is that when you think about
like
insomniac the insomniac purchased the
the spiderman in in
in avengers even the final fantasy 16
exclusivity it's
this dwarfs it all and all those things
are cool
but it really does dwarf it in a way
like it's not in the same league it's
like oh how
you got spiderman nice for you
like you know it's like it's it
immediately
those moves felt like that to me like
right
it's it's it's it's insane it really
isn't saying
what this means and you know it's it's
like i said
earlier it's like i it's like i'm with
benji i don't think this
they had to panic by but i do think this
is something they have to keep in mind
going to next generation uh they have to
look at a couple scenarios i thought
okay these people can come at any time
and be like yo after you finish that
game
here's a billion urs you ain't theirs
anymore
and you know and i'm not even looking at
microsoft i'm looking at google i'm
looking at amazon
and i'm just like you know bluepoint
they
do a lot for them they need to secure
that company
you know kojima games i'm not about that
with that benji but you know that's
that's fine i still would because here's
the thing
here's the thing even if death stranding
wasn't a huge seller they're a team that
has proven they can make a triple a
project
and i'm telling y'all this kind of stuff
is going to be so valuable moving
forward
the thing is is like we don't really
know how invested google
and amazon are right now right we just
don't know like we know that they're
trying some stuff out with stadia
whatever
the the risk you run with these
companies is they have fu money
yeah they can come in if they want you
know we don't know we truly don't know
how
far they're going to go down this road
but if they want they can buy anyone
they want to
so that that's the risk you run is once
the tech giants got involved
it's a whole different ball a whole
different blog now
it's like i said like sony they have to
look into the future they they got to
know that
regardless if some of their studios have
a better quality than
everything microsoft has like the fact
that they can pop out
really quality games consistently a lot
faster than sony
is going to eventually catch up to them
so they have to make that as
as equal as possible before going on
they can't wait like two years like i
would expect
within six months to a year wolf they'll
announce their broader studio at least
one
like because this isn't something small
like this isn't like they went to like
an
indie publisher and bought all those
they bought bethesda
they
store i get yeah yeah but you know the
sony contingent likes the minimum they
brought bethesda no brother
they brought everything they brought
everything that you love
i don't like skyrim but you love doom
got that too so
you gotta understand they purchase
everything everything is something in
that box
that you love and you're never going to
get it it's overfeeding
and that's what i want to do you better
make sure that you go out there and get
yours
let's transition let me finish one
statement
okay you know when back when we were
hearing about the wb stuff
uh you know i was excited about that but
you know
i it was more for i think it could be
good for the brand besides like the
shadow mortar i really like that game
but i wasn't like excited about their
games because i don't really care about
their games like that
but when they but bethesda the thing
that i really enjoy about them buying
bethesda
is what is the key thing that everyone
says that microsoft needs
we need more adult rated games we need
more games that don't look child
but that's the only makes hardcore games
yeah
that's a good point did you guys see the
the league screenshot from uh star field
yeah i i saw one there's two there was
technically two
and what i enjoy about this is you know
they got these studios at the end of the
day
what i really really mess with this is
they have
games that they don't have to rely on
just halo anymore
they got elder scrolls which is arguably
one of the biggest franchises in the
industry
they got you know fallout which you know
fallout 4 and 76 kind of hit it a little
bit for me but it's still a very big
contender
and they got doom which in two games
doom has become one of the most dominant
first person shooters ever made
let me let me even interrupt you with
that what's exciting about it is even
towards the if you want to make an
argument say well some of these
franchises are already declined right
the issue that i i like the
possibilities that excite me is the fact
that
now microsoft is adopting the strategy
of all the studios collaborating with
tech and ideas together and that's
something that solely does
so well so just the idea
of bethesda if even todd howard said it
like they're upgrading
the starfield engine like they had to
make changes and stuff for next year but
what they want to do now
so what i like is the thought of
bethesda having a budget and being
free to create right with this big
powerhouse
behind you back those things excite me
as a gamer
because let's be real you know we can
sit here we can celebrate but there were
some issues with some but destinations
what the excitement is now you've got
like kids that like got filled behind he
bought the ball so it's like okay what
do you mean okay do you need someone to
help you with your water
let me introduce you to rare
that's gonna help you with these
specific aspects of ai or whatever
and it also works vice versa right
because we look at three
four three we say you may need a little
help with your injury
you need a little help with everything
let's fix it all at least
you down the hall to edge software
and let me get you guys into if you
it's just the collaboration potential
is so exciting as a gamer it is so cool
to see
and it's just it's like the king's last
voice like it's delivering
on the promise everyone wanted to know
how truly committed
is microsoft how true when you throw 7.5
billion on the table that's a level of
commitment the xbox base
needed to see adapter make you feel
secure make you feel happy in your
purchase yeah
and i do think that's one of the biggest
thing people really need about i think
that's why japan doubled down
the fact that you know we're we might
have collaborates we never would have
had without this i doubt we'll see a
halo
in doom collab where you know where uh
you know master chief and what's it do
from doom called the
uh doom guy
you know the doom guy master chief is as
as much as an
epic move that is that the just the
sound of that on paper
you know might not not necessarily
happen but
you know it can it but two weeks ago
that was that was completely unrealistic
before we go on to the next one you know
who's benefiting the most from this
who rare and see these they about to
make so many cells so many boats
yeah yeah you think about it because
they add that all right and then
all that other stuff yeah let's get
these super chats all right can i get in
one really
quickly i just wanted to say something
that caught my eye
to piggyback off all the uh all the tech
talk we were talking about there for a
second where people could like share
stuff with each other i sent a tweet out
like uh a little bit
after like i processed everything and i
was like wow this uh
this opens up intex seven for
microsoft's first party
intex seven is an amazing engine you
know anyone that's played doom eternal i
mean
it looks amazing it runs amazing
the thing that caught my eye i sent that
tweet and aaron greenberg liked it
remember when i said that 343 might
throw out that slipstream
uh engine and everybody was like nah
king they invested man money into their
situation well that 500 million don't
look as much as seven
billion now right what what just in
curiosity what studio would you want to
use that engine
i would love to see a halo spin off
because i think infinite's too
late and developed yeah absolutely but a
halo spin off on the hex edge
oh
you let the um the dudes that did uh
uh def loop you let them do that
yeah and they needed that right there
because from what
what we know the you know what we've
been hearing
is the silent hill rumors right right
now could you imagine if they tell tango
check it out
uh make this uh straight up uh this is
the specs
dazzle us you don't have to worry about
anybody else
except for pc and our other spec
uh and we're gonna get into that because
digital foundry did exactly what i asked
them to do
you have been exposed brothers and i'm
gonna get into that you have been
exposed
i'm going to get you so bad this day you
have been exposed
lower spec but this is let's let's shoot
for the stars yeah
and i think because i like the evil
within and i think that's something that
can go against silent hill
and no two and two was amazing yes
amazing and also i want to shout out um
i did not get that out of love with
alpha though because
i know they do a lot of mobile first
party stuff but
stuff are they the people that may fall
as shelter um but yes and
the thing about them though is you got
to remember because
people we have to remember the x cloud
play here
right and when you have studios with
that mobile experience right
and you're gonna put a lot of these
games in gamepad a lot of these games
and regions where xbox consoles are not
traditionally going to be this is the
play
game pass xcloud pc and the xbox
ecosystem
and having a studio with that level of
experience and resources
to to help in that transition is truly
helpful for again the broader vision the
long game
of the next cloud and stuff like that so
i just wanted to point out i didn't get
a lot of love
i wanted to shout them out you know
absolutely i i think one thing that
can't be understated besides the amount
of money that they spent
is the fact that this is not just xbox
investing in gaming
this is satya investing in gaming yes
this is satya telling you that
at the core of microsoft's uh uh uh
thinking moving forward is gaming right
whether it be cloud whether it be
whatever the case may be
um we'll talk about it in a second with
the cloud and stuff like that but i
think
coat well never mind i'll i'll bring
this up when we talk about specifically
what we're going to talk about let's go
to next up let me get these super chats
and then we'll transition hold on one
second so let me first start off with
a new member of the realm shout out to
nelson nieves nelson
brothers horns in there throw the crest
in the chat
let me add this other super chat we have
a bunch of super chats give me one
moment i will scroll back up
all good or good um
we got a ton too yeah yeah okay so we
got
first off we got j ready gossip
super chat beat stops hey king shout out
to game pass
let me clear my throat
[Music]
and we got smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat chris hart microsoft
owns zenimax so they can put whatever
games they want in game pass
men do what they want boys do what they
can do
oh my god shout out to christopher hart
because he's getting rained on in there
in that chat
[Laughter]
that we are squirtly down with two mos
just cut the grass no more snakes in the
yard yeah
that's how you handle it just burn burn
the yard down you have no more snakes
then we have uh avis plush productions
with two dollar super chat demon souls
1440p
60 frames per second so serious worthy
hashtag digital foundry yo i'm going to
get into that
then we have the original next next
level gaming with the fox
thing yeah uh phil said at the table
with the head of zenimax and said i'm
going to write a number on this napkin
and slide it over to you
[Laughter]
it does feel like that like he handed
him the blank check and said fill it out
yourself
like it's crazy um smitty smith with the
five dollar super chat
xbox put the meat on the table now ups
fanboys gotta eat this oh man
jesus
i don't know where that scripture is but
it's in there
that we have jd gaming with the five
dollar super chat with microsoft's next
purchase they will have more studios
than stony nintendo stadia and amazon
combined
looking at the who wins now yeah
i mean they forced that one yeah for
sure
uh then we have j dub as a shill what
the [ __ ]
sony's pockets aren't deep enough they
can't afford a purchase like that
microsoft buys at five-star restaurants
sony buys all food carts wow
the chat is real messy today very messy
we have crazy horse with the five dollar
super chat
the way things are going with the cloud
gaming with amazon google and tencent
microsoft's might might buy sony to save
them microsoft might buy sony to save
them
they might be hilarious sony i mean my
sony made the
i believe the proper bet in going with
uh azure so i i think they're
they're safe in that regard maybe and we
have jd gamer with the father super chat
we got satya out here saying they're not
done who's next a sobo interactive
tech land people can fly vega konami
square enix buy them all
people want microsoft to sega or capcom
can anyone explain how hard it is for
companies outside of japan
to buy a japanese company yeah it is
there's some extras
you need to have a residence right so
them and it has to be over a period of
time i think that zenimax deal
being that tango is there yeah and they
had their residents there
that can extend to purchasing certain
stuff that's
there so if you purchased a building
inside
japan over the last couple of years
where phil was
at least two years ago i don't think
that extends over that period of time
but if tango has been there for a longer
period of time
you can purchase through proxy
through tango to get to sega
it's like tango what goes to buy
something i know now uh
you know i know that you know we're
owned by microsoft but we
we're we're that's our property tango we
know you ain't we we know this is going
to microsoft stop trying to play
yet again found another way to sell
skyrim
coming to then look out for it and
that's what happened for anchor because
he was so angry with the festival
yeah yeah come back into the fall
yeah absolutely absolutely we have jd
gamer with the two dollars which
oh and i think microsoft will eventually
get wb2 wow
i mean hey it once once all these uh
batman games come out and harry potter
comes out
who knows we'll see um then we have
stitch with the five dollar super chat
um time time question in your opinions
which game is bigger spider-man or elder
scrolls
spider-man i don't know i would say
spider-man but
i think the hardcore of these elder
scrolls the hardcore of these elder
scrolls
okay so it just depends um
if it sees okay
it's really actually kind of hard
because it's been so long since
skyrim so it's hard to know exactly what
elder scrolls 6 is going to perform like
especially we'll get into the
exclusivity but if it's just on xbox and
pc
it makes a little bit more interesting
but here's what i can say skyrim is
literally the best-selling
single-player rpg of all time in the
history of the world no game has ever
sold more that's a single-player rpg
we're talking tens of millions like like
tens multiple tens of millions of units
sold so
um it skyrim is way bigger than
spider-man way
bigger but will elder scroll say you
know it's hard to know
if sex will perform like that but i
would say the potential
is there to be bigger than spiderman it
when skyrim being i mean
you know so long ago it makes it harder
to compare but potentially
potentially do you let me just have a
quick question do you think skyrim
supplant now that microsoft is quiet
does that supplant
as the number one ip overall
underneath the uh xbox game studio
banner
if elder scrolls is console and pc
exclusive
and it is received well it is bigger
than halo yes
unless unless halo multiplayer going
free to play takes off but
people don't actually realize like how
big skyrim was like it was
it dwarfed everything yeah i mean it
became
a verb like
well who knows what elder scrolls six is
gonna be like you know they're so
popular they felt uh
they felt the demand to re-release it
like six times
right right that's what i mean it's like
who knows if elder scrolls vi will
perform anything like that but
if it does i mean the potential is there
to be enormous yeah
okay do we have uh next up bravo d3 with
the five dollar super chat
benji do you think hypothetically take
two slash rockstar
are safe or is this even something like
gta and nba 2k not safe from microsoft
amazon google or sony
oh so that is a lot tougher to acquire
because their
market cap is going to be way above even
with bethesda bethesda was privately
owned so we didn't
technically know how much they were
worth right there was a lot of ideas
there's a lot of things like that but
when you're not a publicly traded
company
it's harder to assess an exact value but
take two rockstar all that they would be
way more expensive and we've already
seen seven billion being huge
i would say those you know those
companies microsoft
you know amazon google they have the
money to do it the question
is is once you get to the really big
publishers the eas the active division
that's just going to approve that
yeah you're talking some giant purchases
i mean ea probably 30 40 billion
yes ea alone their market cap is like 38
billion and that's just the market caps
you have to pay
more to actually acquire so the biggest
publishers you know i would say there
are other publishers that potentially
might be bought someone like tech land
some of these other ones are potential
but like the
giants i don't see that happening just
because we're talking any
norm i mean it would dwarf the 7 billion
it would be by
far the biggest purchase so now he will
come become kingfield
by someone like that
god like we're saying
phil all right next up we have victor
alessian with the two dollar sweet chat
xbox did the he-man with bethesda
i have the power yeah we have 700 people
in the chat uh
wow y'all all here to see benji
listen says like follow and definitely
listen to what he has to say god bless
you thank you king thank you so much
that's something
that you know i mean the numbers went up
dude definitely that's fantastic not
following this man on twitter there's
his twitter
go go follow him i appreciate it guys i
i love this is my second time on the
show and i love it it's so much fun
much appreciated thank you brother thank
you uh we have uh next up we restored
hades with the ten dollars of a chat
ever since phil walked across that stage
at the vgas
and announced his generation of xbox you
got world breaker hulk now and now
you're afraid of the power
i hope you've been with me who did that
for you then we got p
diddy papa diddy puff with the two
dollars
they better leave craig alone you see
what happens there
you bully somebody look what happened
um he gets brolic that's what happens he
gets broly oh then we got squirrely dan
with the two dollars we checked king and
i are going to both be playing doom on
october 1st listen
yo at the start of the year king said
i'm going to play it when it comes out
on game pass later this year
y'all didn't believe me but i knew phil
had my back but i'm gonna tell you
something squirrely
this tattoo on my chest said i won't
play with you
you did this to me squirrely you did
this to me
no that was wheel me it wasn't squishy
no
okay i know exactly who pulled that
trigger it was squirrely
who pointed the gun in my direction
it's like that meme squirrely has like
the rocket launcher
and wilmie's loading it like yeah he's
pointing and he's pointing with me to
the to
the right direction definitely a
squirrely definitely uh on
on the first yes sir then we have nelson
nieves with the two dollar super chat
i'm an xbox fan and luna is more
concerning than playstation
yeah of course we're gonna get to that
then we have random citizen with the
five dollar super chat
how many studios does it take to fix
craig's face i need to know
well i thought we heard it i thought jd
gamer was in there savagery savage
did i miss jd gaming yeah with jd game
with the 10 hour super chat
are you there oh okay we got it good
good
we got a 10 dollar super chat from jd
gamer microsoft is about to do a ps
what they did to sega sony used the fact
that they were the biggest
uh the bigger company to bully their way
into the gaming now
uh it's their turn to burn and you know
sega can't win
can't wait to watch oh that that is kind
of really let's just try to ride true
all right then we have dizzy next right
we got disneyland
to join the realm
we have uh disney with the two dollars
five dollars from chat they got mikami
the horror dreaming godfather facts
the man who brought his resident evil
evil within ghostwire tokyo becoming
greater than old
slanderer all right
shout out to dizzy yeah i think we're on
to the last super chat
no we got a few yeah
halo infinite scale yeah that is no i
mean realistically oh it tech is sort of
built for
clothes like cordless or whatnot so yeah
so that's what i was saying is
he says two thousand chad question does
this confirm bethesda it's greater than
much
i'll be the first to admit this
acquisition
by far destroys a the idea of a bunch of
activists even i
as a budgie fan will tell you they were
bugging out what i heard
with the rubik's cube nice they were
that price is crazy when you ask it for
that price
yeah you know as the person but maybe
they can come to a happy medium
and then that whole thing falls to the
wayside because
you know i do believe destiny has
outperformed bethesda
yeah but here's my thing they don't even
need to make the deal in my opinion
because destiny is their big franchise
they already got a sweetheart
right now if
i had to get second meals later i did
not like it she bringing that beyond
light that shadow keep is all in here
that's brand-new she ain't doing that on
the other side
of the second honeymoon stick around i
really think we need to lock her down
she
i think i think we should and i really
think it would be a huge mistake
at the next game because they have
proven they
by any company they have proven they can
switch lanes
and be super successful in the next lane
as they was in the first they started
that halo
and they made something as equally time
five
arcane id and bethesda wow machine games
honorable mention
instantly fix the just what yo salud
they still didn't they still haven't
shown us the third person over the
shoulder
acting game per se but but in terms of
quality of
triple a yes they they solve that
problem i don't need that third person
stuff anymore man
i got elder scrolls man i don't care
because in
addict's world i'm the mayor all right i
don't care
let's move on
[Laughter]
[Music]
i know i know okay then we have jd gamer
with the two dollar super chat microsoft
could buy thq nordic that's big
yeah the teach queue has like a million
in studios now so
yeah okay we're on the last one right
now all right we have
hairy balls with the two dallas super
can they probably technically
will they know i don't think because
here's the thing like sony is actually
sitting on a decent amount of cash on
hand
but whenever you look at it like okay
seven billion dollars is a lot of money
but for microsoft
it's not so like for microsoft seven
billion dollars is whatever that's you
know we can just throw seven billion
around whenever
uh for sony if sony was to spend that
kind of money it's a much
more it's a much more massive chunk of
the money that they have
microsoft microsoft buys that we're like
and we won't get drinks for a couple
years
sony buys is like yo we can't eat we
can't pay anything
it's something fluffy benji it's like
they playstation 5.
so it's either all power or
it's like like that microsoft
it's it's like king said man that's a
slush fund you know
if if sony would out and make that kind
of acquisition that is their nest egg
that's ramen noodles for the rest of the
year
[Laughter]
ken throwing fireballs in the hallway to
keep everybody warm
so just what i'll say is i do think
you're going to see sony buy some
uh developers keep in mind we know that
they were in the bidding to acquire
the uh company behind warframe lelu they
were bidding up to a billion dollars
so a lot of money you know not the 7
billion microsoft was doing
but up to a billion so we do know sony
is willing to spend quite a bit
so i do think you're going to see some
studios acquired from sony
but i don't think you're going to see
anything like a capcom or a square like
an actual
publisher yeah that's that's kind of out
of the thing yeah yeah
we got to catch up now okay then we have
we've got michael aka best.finance
to battle i guess too bad amazon and
google
to battle uh amazon and google sony
needs to team up with microsoft they
have no choice
personal i don't care what so personally
i don't care what sony does but they
need to figure it out honestly
okay i don't think microsoft needs to
team up with anyone but um
we gotta find out super chat from big
cloud gaming salute to the iron lords
from simon brady cd project red
accusation next cyberpunk to game pass
and i'll be
that will be a game over man game over i
told you
it may have cost microsoft 7.5 billion
but
uh but for the price of the super chat
you can uh
you can have all of it who did that for
you great show my friends
let's put the uh let's put the logos in
there for mexican
zoberg definitely definitely what you're
doing
it is what it is i messed it up we know
that's what
finally caught up all right let's go now
now that we've all talked about
where we were how we felt initially the
big question that
kind of was was circulated around the
entire internet the entire week
what does this mean for those ip
traditionally third third-party ips are
all over the place
now they belong to microsoft they've
been arguments on both sides of the
fence for this one
so what do we think what where are these
ip going are they going to stay
exclusive to microsoft and pc
or is phil saying case-by-case basis
really a case-by-case basis or
does that just apply to the two games
that are already exclusive to
playstation for
for a short amount of time what do you
guys think let's start off with lord
benji
okay so when the news very first broke
i'm saying like
that the very first couple hours i
thought
okay maybe the biggest
maybe fallout maybe elder scrolls
stay multi-platform now wait wait just
wait i'm gonna finish
his very first bro and i've switched
live on twitter yeah it did i switched
okay
so i was uh i was thinking okay maybe
the very biggest
they'll keep multi-platform just to
maximize sales but anything from like
arcane is going to be exclusive anything
from id is going to be exclusive
you know that was my very first original
thought but then the more i sat down and
thought about it
the more i i kind of looked at what
microsoft's vision is
i do not believe so anymore no i i think
fallout and elder scrolls will only be
on xbox platforms and pc
i think basically everything will be
outside of possibly games as a service
games so if they do like some
multiplayer type stuff if they do like
another
i i'm not expecting another fallout 76
but you know what i mean that
type of game would not would not
necessarily
shock me to see that go multi-platform
but i think the vast majority of this
stuff is going to be xbox and pc only
including elder scrolls because here's
the thing here's the thing right
microsoft's vision for the future is
about
ecosystem that doesn't mean they're
throwing away consoles it doesn't mean
they're like hey we're out of the
console business it's only about game
pass no they but they do
want you in their ecosystem and if you
put elder scrolls on playstation 5
you are not getting anyone in your
ecosystem yes you're making the quick
buck you are you are scaling that game
on the platform
yes exactly you're going to get some
upfront money but you're not bringing
them
into game pass you're not bringing them
into x cloud you're not bringing them
into
xbox live you're not doing any of that
and so yes i think this is all about
building the future of their you know
company and yeah i don't think these
games are going to playstation at all i
really don't i really
really don't know how many subs to game
past
just bethesda is going to bring in yeah
yeah
no so you know right now
you know that right now they're playing
nice with steam right
do you think that continues or do you
think
by again like you said continuing to to
improve the value of game pass
eventually it's like no you need game
pass on pc to play these games
i think they're staying on steam yeah i
think they're saying on steam
personally just because they've seen so
much success there and i think microsoft
doesn't see steam as a competitive
platform since it's still pc
i mean still kind of all in their
wheelhouse so
steam specifically i do think you're
going to still see their games there i
just think they're seeing too much
success with it
playstation it's a little bit different
to me than steam because at least
you know like i said pcs and microsoft's
evolved beyond just a windows business
but it's still
all in their wheelhouse whereas
playstation put it this way
if sony allowed game pass on playstation
5 i think you would see these games on
places yeah for sure
yeah yeah yeah i think you would
absolutely see it but
sony ain't ever gonna agree to that
that would be admitting that they they
win like that would lowkey be like okay
if this is the only way to get these
games on our platform we're doing it and
that they ain't doing that like
the number jim dance moves ryan is
capable of anything oh yeah he's got a
new nickname now king he's got it
my last statement on it would just be i
just don't see why you would spend seven
billion dollars to put games
at the end of the day when you think
about it it's like why are you spending
seven billion dollars to just put the
game on
competitors you know i just i don't
really get it until you point to double
down your appointment you make a
fantastic point is that
when you look at the other deals for
example look at the ea situation right
and they came into game pass but the
reality is right those weren't
then they if if you're gonna pay 7.5
billion
right the reality is it's ownership
right yes
control of what's going on here and if
it was just about game pass and people
say well they'll miss out on the sony
money
and so on and so forth then they would
have paid less
to get that kind of a relationship right
exactly
it's different you know you have to look
at how these things play out
and we i know we're going to get into
the whole fanboy stuff but
i want to play devil's advocate i've
never done that
there's before lot of people that i see
out there it's actually a
a genuine thing that looks sure it would
be cheaper to do that on a game by game
basic which is ironically what they're
saying about these
games but what they're saying is if you
buy the whole thing
you don't have to do that game by game
you could put them all get uh game pass
day one and on the competitors platform
and like you can do elder scrolls six uh
star field you can do it from here going
on
you don't have to just do it game by
game well the thing is the thing is
what's
in it and it's that double standard
right when sony does it there's less of
a
pushback on it what microsoft does it we
saw what happened with rise of the tomb
raider we thought
when you do it piecemeal like that
microsoft is always going to take a lot
of heat
because the perception is they're not
the market leader how dare they try to
do this right right so what you what do
you do to respond to that
like king said you buy the whole mall
you don't buy the outfit you buy them
all
and then the argument is moot at that
point because it's like
they did exactly what they needed to do
to control every aspect of that
conversation
right it is is it a crazy move yes
but for them it's necessary to control
that because
i think if they go game by game to these
other publishers and say hey i want this
exclusive
i want to buy this i want it for a year
two years whatever
i think that conversation goes less
smoothly with microsoft than it does
with stony because they'll look at sony
like
you're the market leader cool i'll give
you this game for a year
with microsoft they might have been like
i don't really see the benefit to
putting it on your platform and again
it's it's sad but that is the case
that's what it feels like the case is
so they did what they needed to do is
just buy them outright and we control
the entire network
sorry you go benji oh i was just gonna
say and and here's the thing
the other part about making it exclusive
it's like
sony is going out and spending money to
lock down exclusives to their platform
from third parties we already have seen
some announced like final fantasy 16 and
there's gonna be more
here's the thing like whether you view
sony's competition or not however you're
gonna say it
you know they're going out and they're
locking down exclusives
why would you not take the ip that you
own that you spent
all this money on and also lock that
down as exclusive because
your competitor is going out there and
doing exactly that
exactly it
the thing is this this is because i see
a narrative saying the reason why they
have to put it on playstation because
they don't want
microsoft's gonna be viewed as the enemy
and they want to be the nice guy here
here's the reality this is big business
right
and at the end of the day when you look
at the words case by case where in my
opinion that applies to
is things like elder scrolls online
right fallout 76 where these are
mmos who have established communities in
other and playstation games so not to
mention the other company makes mobile
stuff
right microsoft won't do evil in that
regard and
cut off the playstation 5 4 community
in those games because those are
existing communities almost like a
minecraft but when you're talking about
the single player these ips that are now
being developed
you best believe for 7.5 they want to
control them all they want to control
like benji said putting it into their
ecosystem
the best way to get people into
ecosystem is not just a 70 dollars quick
up front money
where sony's gonna take you know 30 you
know what i'm saying off the top
they want you in that reoccurring xbox
game pass subscribe
that is more valuable to this that's
been short
70 dollars people have to get this out
of their head and so the last point with
the narrative is just that look
this is a business sony has been doing
this for a long time
and and rightfully so they've brought up
cachet in the brand
and we've had this conversation before i
didn't see people crying when street
fighter 5
arguably the greatest fighting games of
the
digital
it was exclusive to that platform right
this is just business you're trying to
get people into the ecosystem that's
all this is the playing the play has
always been game pass it's always
played if you're trying to grow your
ecosystem
there's no way you he's going to force
them to bend the knee
to go fast i'm of the mind at this point
the argument that you can only get one
platform
it's kind of move even even considering
some dudes can't afford that man
no bro but now we're gonna have to pick
and choose now baby now baby
i don't buy it anymore can't cut like no
i buy it i don't
think i've seen i've seen dudes go
shopping i buy it
um listen let me let me tell you enough
of this enough of this
you'll reap what you sow before you go
on your rant because i know it's going
to be admitted we have a couple right
before it's going to be a minute yeah
what king goes on his rant that's
probably going to end the whole
segment so i want to get my bars off
before
uh do we have any super chats we want to
give you let me let me get these real
quick we have did we get one bad mother
it may with the 10 super chat it may
have gone right because 7.5 billion
but for the price of this super chat you
two can have it
we got that yeah we have we have a
battery
okay baron with the five dollars which
if sony does not double down on ps now
in 10 years
they will become the like sega and make
games only we're seeing gaming
netflix versus blockbuster let me let me
get this kid smooth we got a ten dollar
sweep shot from kid smooth
temper steam only started getting xbox
first
party games after agreeing to let street
uh steam users
log into xbox live to access the games
steam ultimately did that because epic
was securing a lot of content and that
is true
and i think that's one of the reasons
you saw ea go back on there because it
forced steam
to be realistic that okay epic is not
playing i need to actually
not be nice yeah so that yeah let's go
to
i think for the most part it seems like
we're all sort of in agreement that
these aren't going anywhere still got
more yeah
we got three more yeah yeah yeah one
five five three d
one final chance not getting past the
playstation x cloud the playstation
playstationers can always play can
already play
on their phones and hook that up to the
tv xcloud or playstation takes that
takes out that phone and gets
subscriptions yep that's right
all right so let me yeah let's do these
last super chats and i'm going to say
something before we pass up
uh we have shiloh with the five dollar
super chat heard that phil went to the
store and bought some reese's for some
private he decided to give one of those
cups to jim ryan
we got smitty smith with the five
dollars with that this is big business
7.5 billion do not care how you were
viewed to hell with
the feelings the book of acts
oh my god then we have microwave
bestsellers fine it's two dollars super
chat do maternal and game pass next week
thank you
phil hello what i want to get mars off
though
what i want to bring up is
we already have examples of this you
know i understand people like bringing
up the minecraft thing and i get to
to a point i can understand people's you
know point with
okay minecraft was a multi-billion
dollar thing uh then you know that's why
that is
multiply i don't think that was it i
think that minecraft wasn't bought for
gaming
at all minecraft was bought for uh you
know selling uh
selling toys licensing out the movies
obviously was bought for games too but
it was mainly bought for everything else
in general and not just gaming
it felt like it was a corporate move
more than a yeah what would it co
let's let's go back a couple years to
when they bought all those studios
all right that was a lot of money too
people act like that was chump change
no that that was that was a lot of money
yeah that's a big acquisition
and you know i'm assuming that was over
a billion too at least
over a billion because i was told it was
rumored that they spent like what four
to six hundred million just on
playground games
so you know let's let's look at that
scenario you know when
all that stuff came out we had the outer
worlds
the reasons that these games weren't
exclusive
is because they had a third party deal
that was not part of that company
that was a publisher that's not the case
here they bought the whole publishing
license
okay then you know after that came out
my question to everyone that wants to
use that scenario
is a vowed is that an exclusive yes
right hellblade two is that an exclusive
yes i mean grounded that's an exclusive
bleeding edge that's an exclusive my
question and the thing i want to point
out is
do you guys think that two years ago
they made this investment
and these games are exclusive do you
think just because they spent a few
billion dollars more
that that to me hellblade 2 if that was
the vision
if they if they wanted companies just to
make it day one on game pass
those games would be coming to
playstation okay to become a playstation
yeah exactly
and that's what shows you that the play
was always game package if a couple
years
i don't think that the visions change
like that i think
the vision back then was we're buying
these studios to make our ecosystem
because regardless
you know a lot of people say oh you know
xbox doesn't care about the consoles
anymore
they care about them it's just not the
focus anymore they know that the
the xbox is still yeah the xbox is a
device to get to their ecosystem
they're focused on the ecosystem but
they still want to sell consoles
because it gets you to their ecosystem
yes
i think i think the xbox anything to
playstation conversation only happens
when there's no box that they're selling
you
and as long as phil's in charge he said
that's not happening
so i i don't see that happening so uh to
kind of expound on what you guys have
been talking about especially to
the the super chat that talked about the
game pass not game past the ps cloud to
playstation but xcloud
um i gotta give a shout out to cole
eastwood because colt put up a video
yes that was he simplified it for
everyone that's had that has this
argument about
no they're going to playstation this is
why he basically took
a circle a circle chart a circle a pie
graph right
a hundred percent of the gaming uh of of
the gaming sort of uh companies
and he divided it up right he basically
divided up into three sections
mobile gaming console gaming and pc
gaming right
and he highlighted all of the aspects
all the aspects
take it for someone who does artwork and
stuff that took that man hours
yeah he simplified it in such a way
because he highlighted
in green all of the areas that microsoft
is trying to touch with all aspects of
their ecosystem whether it be game pass
whether it be xcloud
everything he's trying to touch when you
look at that
and you tick and you take out the the
hundred
you know 12 15 million playstations in
the console gaming space
it is a very small number compared to
what they can reach as a whole with
their ecosystem as it is
it doesn't make sense for them to have
spent this amount of money it's just
logistics
it honestly it there really is
no argument to be made right just
logistics
logistics the reach that they have with
xcloud
and with game pass and with just a pc
market
right it allows them to penetrate the
the mobile market
the pc market and continue to grow
their their market share in the console
market so
it doesn't make sense to sort of if you
want to talk about diminishing
properties and diminishing the sort of
the the what
the the wealth of your properties or the
value of your properties
put put those games on playstation that
would do that
that would do that so yeah it's not
happening guys
it's just not happening so that last
point too before i get king and
everybody
is that you made a good point solving
the sense that you also have to
understand the console market
there's a ceiling there's a certain
ceiling that at that point
you're not going to exceed it right it's
i don't know whether it's because it's
mobile phones whatever but it has shown
that there's a certain number
every year more and more people head
towards the mobile market
so basically when the console generation
starts it's these companies fighting for
that share
of that field right now when you go in
pc
and then you throw in the mobile market
now you're expanding upon it and that's
where the game pass play comes
that's where the x cloud stuff comes in
you know i'm saying because that is what
they're ultimately trying to do again we
have to stop
we're so used to the consoles driving
our mentality and the old way of
thinking that's the only way
well that's the only way right
you just said the old way and i was just
clarifying for the public
for the tcl users i'm just letting you
know that he was talking about the sony
wave oh
and by the way i'm no longer the tco
ambassador we won't go into why
but i'm no longer the team
shout out to that hdr in your eyes we're
no longer we're not talking about that
today a thousand nits baby
thousand nits looking that's pretty much
what i want to say
it's just that it's a different way of
looking at it but let me let me give it
a moment i think jake is up
yes sir like i was saying you reap with
yourself
like i was saying you reap what you sow
what's good for the goose is good for
the
gander you were having such a good time
exclusives baby exclusives
drive the market exclusive is the reason
we purchased
well now brother put your money where
your mouth is
because exclusives is the reason why
you will have another king what happens
if someone comes up and asks you i don't
care what they talking about
if you don't have an xbox right now
something wrong with you
he gave you seven billion reasons why oh
he said who doom uh huh what
because at first you heard justin i
don't care about destiny being in game
pass
how about doom though how about that
skyrim though
you fall out boys right how you about to
do fall out boys how y'all doing over
there
so all that street fighter stuff
remember that hot i had to purchase a
playstation 4
street fighter x i had no choice
and y'all was sitting there loving it
because you know exclusives make you
purchase well guess what
guess what that and he made something
just for you
he made this because you got that
gigantic box you got that big heater
that you have right next to your tv he
put a nice little small
joint that that's gonna be right nicked
in the way you can hide it from your
friends
play so what you can do is you can hide
the console
you can make people think that it's a
playstation and you can pull your
control out when they're not watching
and you can play your xbox listen listen
sony fans i'm giving you
exactly how you gonna get it done so
when you go to the store make sure you
got on your covet mask
go by you make sure you got it on your
head
just
you know why you gonna say let me get
that ass because you're a tcl dude
so we know how you move so you're gonna
go get that ass and listen listen listen
listen the series is just as good as
your playstation five
because digital foundry just exposed you
dudes
1440p is down for you so look
oh my god now that we understand what
you need
you want to get your skyrim on you won't
get your doom on
remember exclusives is the reason why
you buy
so you have no choice now all that
please kind sir
please on my playstation
no no tiny tim there will be
delivery is coming this week and i said
thank you thank you
i got boxes and boxes of knees and i
might need some of your sony guys to
help me put them in oh you can't help
because you ain't got no knees
i just got one question for you who did
that for you
i've never been so happy to be so lucky
i've never been so happy to be so right
because i'm watching
worm and wiggle and cry because you got
to get out an extra 325 dollars out of
your pocket
cause you're gonna buy the s you ain't
gonna buy the x right he's looking good
you're gonna want to be a super fan so
you're gonna have to buy
that s and i am so happy for you
i will
you were told right from a certain base
that
you know sony treats their customer like
vip
trust tony does these things and makes
these moves and exclusives
and in defense of the xbox base there
were no tears [ __ ]
from them when these games were
explosive and you had to go get it
playstation that was it at the end of
the day when i wanted to play street
fighter 5
i had to get the playstation when i
wanted to play final fantasy 7
i had to get literally just bought a
playstation yeah
so if you are truly a gamer you're going
to go
in person you know you know what cognito
yeah
i want to play demon sus guess what i
gotta do i gotta go get it exactly
it just comes down to being a gamer
again
and this is the funny part you know what
this is king
incognito this is just a bunch of people
talking about games they didn't care
about
so they didn't care if they had to go
get a console but when you take
something for ransom
he's like yo i got i got that doom i got
the dude in the back you're going to pay
that money
they're like um i want it to be known
i want every every time a playstation
owner
goes to buy a series s and when you're
in gamestop when you're in best buy
where you
wherever you are and yo let me get an
s
i want them to do it nice and loud and i
want when your credit card to go in
you know swipe card don't work right
there they're like oh hold on hold on
hold on we got to wipe this you having a
problem sir no no oh my god
i want everybody to acknowledge you you
have crossed picket lines
to give you a nice xbox scarf or a hat
somebody's
gonna find you with a new purchase
that you are here with us thank you hey
i'm
sorry i'm just saying benji if you have
something you have to do man feel free
to tell us at any time
oh i i have to be at work at 2 30 but i
mean i got time
i just wanted you to i just wanted you
to know that yes
exactly like the lord get benji out of
here
oh my just tell the man you know if if
you got something you have to do
you always act like i'm sitting you're
giving people information
when you ask him that before we go live
i know but
he was looking he was looking at his
phone so i thought he was looking at him
then i'm going to be on the iron lords
and they probably text him like oh my
god he said that
that's what he probably the last time
the last time he was on he's like next
time i'll be on with you guys i'm gonna
rock with you guys the whole time
like i said
uh listen last didn't i say last week
these companies are liars
they're all liars they lied to you
they told you listen jim ryan was like
we believe in generations
now you don't know bill spencer said
oh you know first bro you know first
party exclusives aren't necessarily as
important as they
you know as people make them out to be
yes they are
they are we just gave you 7.5 billion
reasons why they are
they're louder they're all liars to you
that's why the allegiance to
any box per se is foolishness
like god said be a gamer game yo i got i
gotta shut out 108 man because 108
is always out there and forte always out
there touting
this message game game you
if you come out here and you have it and
that's why i told k that's why i was
saying ken
king i don't buy that argument anymore
that you can only get one platform
there's ways around it now there's you
know even if you can't get i've never
bought that
i've never bought that these people have
access it's emotions they're getting
emotionally attached
that's what it
this is why i don't buy his argument i
literally sat
there while a guy came online
this person is going to be a whole
demographic he brought
all the in this person could be
everybody in every state some place i
i know every line at gamestop had one of
these dudes he brought all his video
games
he had it in the bag and he was this is
it i got to trade it in
so i could put the down payment on my
system whatever the system is
i don't know what he was coming to get
you know he could have been he could
have been on xbox line trying to get a
playstation
available and put my money up not
everybody
has the same uh wallet as you know that
is true that's
right and people go into i don't bother
he's right
somebody's doing it i i make almost
minimum wage and i can get both
these holiday things you can come out of
a gamestop or a walmart for 200 dollars
it's emotions these people sit there
they're buying their entire
soul into a box and they're like i'm not
leaving it's mine like i don't know
i'm gonna follow up then he has the
numbers a lot of this is casual
purchases
yes and these casual people choose one
for a generation
that i agree with the casualty and okay
and i may be
wrong by saying that you can't afford it
but it's not even about that
it's about the casual purchase those
individuals go in
and they decision is based on is doom on
that box
yes
and they tell them oh i'm rocking with
playstation all night long
and he actually going ghost on xbox
invisible playing their games
so i know who you are i see you all the
time but i don't want you to lie to your
fan base i tell the truth i got
everything i choose to play on microsoft
i'm
forced to play on sony and then and the
window is getting
smaller and smaller for you dudes look
at the other day i'll just say this
point
attic i know what you're saying the the
income is there people can get it
but what tends to happen is people tend
to make an informed decision right and
they say to themselves look
all i'm going to be doing is this
activity from a cabinet standpoint or
this game
and they just say practically it just
makes sense to get one
and then what they do they see where
their friends are going and then they
double down on that decision
and that's generally how how it works
and that's always saying so a lot of it
comes down to
people want to dig in and justify that
singular purchase
and thus the tribalism and all that
stuff stays in but if you're a gamer
right just like we are when ghost
shashima came out i was picking up yeah
my sony was already here so i was good
to go
you know i had everything in place
already
so that wherever these games go i'm not
going to be emotionally destroyed
or because oh i can't get it because how
dare they you know they should open
these
the floodgates open and let me in you
know
we love that game go out to the great
example
a great example i love final fantasy
games
and i'm sitting here i'm sitting here on
the attic show saying sony should
probably look into buying square enix
they got a good relationship they could
probably make that happen more than
anything else
knowing i have to buy playstation if
they buy that company
like because i have to play the final
fantasy games like
i think it comes down to is some of
these you know
hardcore people get emotional i think
it's just games
this generation let's be real the play
the xbox games was lacking for the most
part
and there wasn't a whole lot of reason
to own an xbox platform next generation
it's not like that
like i like that wow and and last point
is again and this is for k you know
if you bully someone and tell them their
whole life
and have no games right if you bullied
they really did get tired of being like
a song and a rich kid who got bullied
and said okay
i'm buying this whole thing when i grow
up
and all this other stuff they want you
in the ecosystem
that is the play you're bending the knee
to game pass that's it
um all right let's get these super chats
and we'll move on to the next
part of this uh topic real quick
we got restored hades with the 5 super
chat xbox having the games all available
on pc and with game pass being available
on mobile pc
xbox and some tvs ask you do they need
to support
psn no oh not at all not at all we have
lord brat for the two dollar super chat
kings
pc master race no no no he's buying a
series x you know
i forgot how many of these people this
entire generation said there's no reason
to get an xbox there's no reason to get
an xbox
i'm not getting a series x and then what
happens every single one of these people
you know what i'm going to do
where are all the guys that got all
these pcs that don't need xbox now
remember that that was
i see so many of these look at that look
at the yeah
what's funny is people literally went
out to game
to clown on xbox for not having a great
line
but they're they're getting an x like
i just remember all these things there
was no need for the uh xbox there
there's none
there's no need no need
sony got the ps fanboys trained well
sony step one
blow into the controller sony don't be
scared just to take part
that was funny as hell the book of acts
once again new scripture into the book
of acts
um then we have stitch with the five
dollar super chat today's scripture for
the iop book of acts
it's incredible the prophet king david
i'll be who did that be okay there's a
whole bunch of emojis
then we have the wise old gamer with two
dollars super chat full made
xbox series s for sony what does the s
stands for
very sony then we have webhead 420 with
the five dollars super chat shout out to
the lords love the show
uh love the show much keep up the good
work
we have saved two we have forte hold on
oh we have forte with the two dollar
super chat hell yeah sub
games is why we play not platform
thank you um we got the two sage with
the ten dollars
cognito remember what i said let attic
know sony isn't going to buy square
because they already have a suitor with
deeper pockets
after that remember what i said
they need some japanese blood all right
so let's move on to the the next aspect
of this
um so two years two years ago kaga and i
were sitting next to each other at the
bethesda conference
and when they announced orion we looked
at each other and were like
another player in the space very
interesting
and they were touting some some kind of
bonkers sort of performance levels
talking about
pc settings uh max pc settings
4k 60 frames per second
no perceivable lag and we raised an
eyebrow to that
so cog yeah what do you feel about
now that that that uh but that well
xenomax
and microsoft are better but that's the
attic
and microsoft fellows what does this
mean
for cloud in general
definitely listen i think this is one of
the most
understated aspects of the deal because
um
at the end of the day like i said like
you said you know we were there
in the bethesda conference 2019 in that
crowd whatever
and um at the end of the day this tech
again
it's from my understanding it's sdk so
it's a crowdfunding sdk that's going to
be in engine
and according to you know bethesda with
this orion tech you know they're able
to really control latency even better i
think right now
you know project x cloud's about 720p
you know
30 seconds right but it's using the xbox
xbox one s as the blade right so it's
not the x yes
that's not the maximum but most of the
most people
don't have an issue because it's on a
smaller screen right
but now if you are able to do something
in
engine right when you can reduce this
latency
it will be interesting to see you know
how this tech is now
leveraged now that microsoft you know
has ownership of it with this whole deal
so i think a lot of it also comes down
to the barriers of
you know a lot of the connection
connections being optimal whether it be
a five gigahertz wi-fi
or you know high quality 5g and stuff
like that again xcloud works fine
as it is but it almost again if the tech
is as advertised we still have to see it
in the wild what we saw was
let's be honest a controlled environment
but one thing is for sure if it in any
way
could improve the latency and that
relationship with xcloud to give these
seamless experience
this could be a another cool for
microsoft for that long-term play
that they are of shaken out so i just
wanted to bring it to the realm i
thought it was interesting
that he gave me you know love the heat
here and read this kind of stuff
and when we speak to people who are in
the know you know from my
understanding this is on an in engine
level this is different this is also not
as reliant
on your proximity to a data center or a
cloud service so
this is really cool stuff and i'm i'm
very interested to see
how they leverage i don't know if um
benji was following any of this at all
like that but i just wanted to bring it
to the table for sure for sure bendy uh
what are your thoughts on this yeah i
mean streaming is gonna become just more
and more
and more important as time goes on you
know it's one of those things
i feel like phil's made it really clear
that to them they don't view streaming
as like something that's going to just
take over the industry
no one's going to be on consoles like
you know they see it as
additive to the market but the thing is
is it's just going to continue to grow
especially in emerging markets right
like it's easy to think here in in a lot
of places you know people have the
disposable income maybe to drop
600 bucks or 500 bucks on consoles and
games
but for a lot of markets you know you
might have a cell phone
um and you might have a decent internet
connection because believe it or not
even in a lot of emerging markets they
have
pretty decent internet internet
infrastructure is definitely
improving worldwide so anything you can
get any piece of tech that you feel like
is gonna make your streaming offerings
better reduced latency things like this
it's all important because as we see
google has made attempts with stadia we
have
amazon coming in we have microsoft
trying to put xcloud everywhere
so it's one of those things i don't know
that we're ever going to get to a point
where
you know streaming just takes over the
entire market but it is going to become
a thing that a lot of people use
so i definitely make sense yeah bringing
in as much
good tech as possible to increase your
your your tech is good thing
absolutely and my last point i'll make
it like i said
again these are additive things we know
the play
obviously the elephant is in the room
you know amazon
[ __ ] is here you know shout out to uh
dizzy he's got a fantastic article right
now
and um it they people people could say
this
we know people laughingly stated we get
it you know what i'm saying they want to
prepare with the game
but one thing we do know is amazon's
actually been lurking for a while
they've had you know they've had their
footprint in in gaming for
household studios and things of that
nature you know we do know from a
performance standpoint they're 1080p
60 you know 4k coming soon you see the
ubisoft deal
and at the end of the day the footprint
of amazon is tremendous in your
perspective you know i work for a tech
company
you know aw aws is very private you know
and also king
let you know you know just people having
access to like amazon movies and music
and not realizing it just because they
have pride for using it for shipping
you know these are four things that they
use to penetrate the market so
yeah into king's words you know the
white walkers are here
like they are here and i know people
like look they get they gotta prove it
to me
they have to show me the commitment
again i get that that is fair right
but off the bat it's definitely a better
position
than stadia so i agree we have to not be
over confident if you're microsoft you
can't be overconfident
like benji was saying also when it comes
to these studio acquisitions
this is where the player is going to get
interested because
amazon's going to be looking to play
they got this stupid money
you know google's looking to play people
are looking to get
their footprint in so these are things
we got to be cognizant of we just can't
pooh-pooh it and say oh it's amazon they
don't have a chance
these are the reasons why projects cloud
are doing things and at the end of the
day competition is good for the market
even in the streaming space and
hopefully this will help i think the
only way
that stadia does anything is if stadium
if google and amazon
come together to do an uh a streaming
platform
i don't think them independently is
going to do anything like that's my
opinion
i think what happens in the long term is
that i think the display with orion and
and xcloud
makes a lot of sense like like cox said
because it is an additive thing to what
x-class already has
on the hardware because it's sdk and
it's software-bound it's something that
could be thick to be
put out to everything that they have
right and we know that we we're going to
get series x
uh blades coming later this uh in 2021
or the beginning of that um when you
look at like
like what attic was saying about them
joining together that would be a very
difficult proposition just on a
logistical from a logistical standpoint
because stadia runs on linux
right um it would have to be a complete
like
you're dropping one or the other well
they're going to do something
is definitely not it right now right
yeah luna is windows-based y'all
it's a big windows based big deal it is
when you look at the amazon offering and
and their reach
they're they are the white walkers
really like
stadio has put themselves in a position
where they're they're coming from a
point of weakness in term
in terms of how they decided to to sort
of present
stadia and sell stadia and but if that
changes
then that conversation changes as well
but right now amazon
knowing their reach knowing the the aws
and how prominent that is and everything
that they do
um yeah they if you need to worry about
anybody in the in the now very crowded
streaming space it's amazon right shout
out to dude robin he says why do people
want to stream not even mobile games
again you're thinking
from a selfish north american
perspective
you have to think outside the box again
where the console is not it's not a
priority where
xbox consoles are not a priority like
these are things
that markets the mobile space is bigger
than you think and a lot of people shout
this up so yeah it's bigger than the
console this game that
is the long-term play especially asia
yes yes for us as gamers we our region
doesn't care as much
right but these are the legions like
benji telling benji like this
is what the play is i'll let you i'll
let you elaborate with these operations
yeah just just i was going to say like
particularly this
has potential to be very big in asia
asia is a gigantic market in general for
mobile
um i mean dwarfs consoles not even close
in general so you know there's no
guarantee that things like xcloud or
luna or things like this will take off
in those asian markets
but i'll tell you what i mean if you can
if you have one of these services
really blow up over there uh i mean the
potential in those markets particularly
is enormous
exactly that's why you see the deals
that these guys are making like that on
xbox with
sk telecom stuff like that trying to get
it into the ip trying to get it into as
many spaces as possible
that's what they're trying to do man
that's the continuous improvement of the
tech like
right now we're talking about xcloud you
know 720p 30 frames per second
but with the advent of something like
orion we we're talking about people if
you don't have access to a console you
choose not to game on a console and you
are in one of these regions where
the mobile is huge imagine being able to
you know have whatever uh uh a 1440p or
a 4k monitor
like that or a tablet or something like
that and be able to run these games at
60 frames per second
exactly it is an investment in
continuing to improve
the tech that is that has to show you
that it's the way forward like they're
not they're not investing all the money
in time
just to drop it it's not exactly and
sometimes it's just a matter of getting
there first
because then you've established yourself
and then once you get that first you
become
synonymous with what that is and look
how netflix and these things start i
mean
this is a this is a big play man i know
games a lot of us don't care about
mobile games i just wanted to bring it
up but
we can move on with the benches all
right okay
specifically i i really couldn't care
less about
uh amazon has been uh in the gaming
space for a little while
uh they've been testing the waters and
what you fear
this this is the reason why you know uh
phil and microsoft feel that the
nintendo
and sony aren't competition they're not
strong in the area that they know that
everything is going to go into
they're looking at the people that have
the infrastructure that can actually
dominate and the wallet
that can actually push that
infrastructure forward
so when you look at google and you look
at amazon
you start to realize that if they ever
woke up
see this is the thing everybody always
said and solomon said
earlier why does microsoft play the
little book the the little kid
and he has the biggest wallet
at a point in time where he could have
just dominated the market
if we we all wanted bill gates to
actually just buy everything
and just control games right like he
could have did that right
but why are they playing little brother
now microsoft has
established their self in the gaming
space to a point where
there are people on the board that see
what's valuable
and where they can make magic money
right
you don't want the right person in
charge in google
and and i know full luminous was never
that dude
um
[Laughter]
and over at amazon if they have the
right people in place this thing can get
really dangerous really fast like benji
was saying
they can purchase and they can go out
and they got fu money
they can just go out and say you know
what ea you're doing nice
you're mine and that will change the
landscape
dramatically could you imagine if you
can only
get madden and and 2k and all these
games
all this stuff i'm on the 2k1 rockstar
but um
madden you know fifa and all these other
games ufc and stuff
only in lumina could you imagine if you
can only get it in stadia
so it's this is the white walkers this
is the real fight the real fight
is these giant companies
that has the disposable income that can
just come
in and they can they can just wipe out a
whole
area build a campus
for their new studios that's that type
of money that i'm talking about
it's not just you purchasing these
studios
they got town money where they can
purchase a town
wipe it clean and start with their whole
studios
there so be very careful with what
you're looking at because it's not very
easy to do that you when you go to
redmond see congress
when you go to redmond
how did it look when you got there you
see y'all see
google's uh uh like campus you see
you see redmond microsoft campus these
are campuses
you know they buy little sections of
cities
and you gotta you gotta really know who
you're dealing with so a lot of
people think oh now sony is rocking it
sony's not buying no city
you're out of control
the other day it's investment you know
you got
if you want to make your marks here you
want to be dominant there you've got to
put in the money you got to put in the
software you've got to cater to games
and demographics that you are weakened
and with consoles it's not to play there
all right i hope they don't wake up yeah
you don't want to wake the sleeping
giant you don't
like you better be careful you got to
watch what you wish for sometimes right
because yeah
um let's get this fight let's get these
let's get these super chats real quick
and then we'll move on
um xbl uh with the 10 super chat i wish
phil would just say these games will be
exclusive
shut that ish down and don't give ps5
fam boys hopefully
they're riding the high right now how do
you keep a fool in suspense
i think if the shoe was on the other
foot there would be any questions no
there wouldn't be any questions but
you guys had to remember that the the
deal isn't uh
it hasn't fully taken effect yet right
so
you know when that happens we'll get
definitive statements yeah it is
kind of funny that they're kind of
talking around the subject oh yeah
but like i said logistics will tell you
that it doesn't make any sense that they
wouldn't be doing anything i went back
and i looked uh
i i searched everything with aaron
greenberg phil spencer anyone you could
think of in terms of
play too well i'm just saying real quick
like
they didn't comment on them either so
they left that completely mystery the
first time we knew that was
definite exclusive is when they showed
it at the veggies let's let's breeze
through these topics
let's get looking at these topics right
real quick web head five dollars with
the final switch
you guys think xl could blow up in
popularity over in japan like benji said
um yeah if it's the if you have the
right games for them
and the service is good it could
potentially blow up absolutely so
uh one more jonathan b five dollar super
chat can anyone confirm where cog is at
in the at the
moment how do we know that he's in the
studio and bringing
in he's in microsoft building brokering
deals
i could either confirm
oh man all right
so real quick uh real quick on these
xbox series pre-orders uh
there were not a lot of them out there
right so
just re does this get everybody's
thoughts on
how it went did you get your did you
didn't did you not get yours
let's talk about that so uh let's talk
with benji um yeah i got a series x
pre-order
i'll tell you what it was it was a
nightmare to secure it but i did manage
to get one so i do have my series x
pre-ordered i'm pretty stoked about it
um yeah in general it doesn't look like
there was much it looks at least
as of now that sony had more consoles up
for pre-order than microsoft so that
will be interesting to see how that
goes moving forward this is just looking
at like channels and stuff this is
uh you know this isn't concrete i'm not
saying for sure i know that they had
more but
all evidence points to that more ps5
consoles were available to pre-order
than xbox
so i am curious to see how their
manufacturing is going and how many
units they're gonna have
actually for launch um like in stores
i'm very curious to see how they compare
because we know that sony
has committed to more ps5s this holiday
than there were ps4s at launch
so we know that they're going to have a
pretty strong amount of inventory i'm
very curious to see what microsoft's
current plans are because they haven't
really given like an exact statement
like
we're going to have more series x than
we had xbox once i tend to
think between x and s there will
probably be more than there were ones on
the market but
we don't know 100 sure what inventory
looks like yeah
absolutely what about uh what about
addict how did you do i
think is you hate benji now i i don't
think you fear that
oh no it's me i'm sorry my brother came
here asked me a bunch of dumb questions
i didn't get one unfortunately i didn't
get one
okay i went there there was only six at
the
the gamestop i had there was 15 people
in line so uh
i saw that and went to get something to
eat went home i was like i'm not sitting
there i'm not doing that for a
zero percent chance of getting anything
for sure um i
i think the way both of these console
manufacturers have handled this
is pretty sad but you know that that's
just me i'm i'm upset mainly because i
didn't get one i'm glad everyone else
got one but i
i was not one of those people i mean
i guess that's the that's the word with
everybody how about you [ __ ]
yeah it was it was it was spooky for me
um i had like six tabs open
you know best buy target walmart
microsoft all that stuff
and obviously i'm working remote so i'm
just like what is going on you know you
refresh it i had a couple in my cart
they said they were ready to go
target did me dirty then i had amazon
and best buy ready to go
and the time came and they was they were
not available i'm like
update their splash screen like what's
going on so they did me dirty
game stop it was looking bad so what i
ended up doing
what saved me is i went to xbox.com
signed in and i had to keep refreshing
and i was able to get into my car and
the funny part is
i get it into my cart and the the green
icon to place order will not
light up and i'm like what is going on
like it's i have it it won't let me
purchase
i'm going crazy and i had to re-look at
the screen a couple times and it looked
like
they had a bunch of addresses down for
me because i guess you know being on
xbox live moving around all over the
years
and though i said oh and then i clicked
the address and then once i clicked
picked this address did it lit up and it
went through us i was lucky that i was
able to get an x
and shout out to cole i was able to help
him get it as shout out to a couple of
people
who are really struggling i'm trying to
give people links shout out to wario 64.
a lot of people
are putting up you know links and stuff
trying to really help people
secure one because it was man it was it
was fists out here these streets
it was it was crazy how about you okay i
got three
all right i was out there hustling i was
out there
i was on the gamestop line and um
somebody it's just a real real quick
story uh
somebody tried to cut the line
i don't know yeah so you know wifey came
up and i you know
and she was coming up i was like yeah
taking off my bracelet taking off my old
yeah i said if you
try to take that paper i'm gonna knock
you out
oh my god his brother
and his girlfriend was in the front like
his local brother and his girlfriend and
and she she was doing the talking
because i told the dude i said
um you and your girl is secure y'all
been here your boys showed up
i said it's going to be a point in time
in this conversation i'm not gonna say
another word
and i i i gave my wife the phone and i
said joe just press record
and i said i want to hear somebody yell
our world start i said this is going to
be the quickest
thing that you've ever seen in your life
[Music]
so the girl came out to take the orders
and
you know the dude tried to i said if you
touch that paper i'm knocking you out
and at that point
she looked over and was like yeah
you get off the line you get away ran
over the side
you measured the situation it was like
now it's definitely a dirty situation
but um i got
a an x and i got an ass and then i wind
up getting another one from um
um amazon but uh yeah the the orders
look kind of
weird but i blame it on taco bell right
now because taco bell apparently got a
lot of winners and they got a lot of
coffee yeah
i'm a little frustrated with that to be
honest with you i gotta go buy tacos
bell today
i'm gonna go eat taco bell i haven't ate
fast food in two weeks
microsoft you're the reason i'm going
off my diet i'm getting a salad i'm
getting something
for regulation it's not the first salad
you've got to keep for regulating
fairness on pre-order
no no you're going to you're going to
respect the sanctity of the line are you
going to
time
is that i think this was calculated i
mean only
from an urgency standpoint i think
the bethesda announcement was calculated
but actually hurt hardcore gamers
because they brought so much of
attention to writing some such a fever
pitch
around the day before your pre-order
so now you got all these people here and
i just think
like that was such a shot in the arm to
pre-order
this cocktail that i'm like yo i might
not get this this is looking spooky
yeah real quick uh big shout out to
first off big fat eli
and uh one of our followers he was
giving us a sort of heads up to go to
the microsoft store and stuff like that
so he helped us out a lot
um uh um kybasa managed to get his to
the microsoft store
um shout out to kai basu for doing the
lord's work i was at work and my my
internet connections in the bushes
so he was online with multiple tabs open
trying to get it done
and once again like so he got his from
the microsoft store i managed to get
mine from
amazon um and the thing is i thought
i thought i got in late to amazon
because i didn't realize that the
pre-orders didn't go up i just thought
the site was dead like i was like oh the
pre-orders
must have been gone in a second and i
didn't realize that they just came
they they went up late so i kind of feel
like i was at the front of the line then
when it comes to that so i did get the
email of death
you guys i really do i hate you we will
exactly exactly i would have told you
the early bird gets the worm make sure
that she was up at two o'clock in the
morning like the rest of us
acting like he was there at two o'clock
no i actually i was there four
mm-hmm at four o'clock
see i'm not this is not new this is time
time let's go we gotta go man we gotta
go
let's close that brings up our show
for this week shout out the lord ben
details for joining us for the entire
podcast
thank you thank you thank you thank you
this gentleman like we said the last
time he was on the show this gentleman
everything that he does in terms of
industry analysis he does on his own
he's he all the research everything is
on his own he is by
himself what he does is absolutely
amazing you need to give this man a
follow on twitter and on youtube
um i've never seen a single person put
so much hard work into
sort of creating an a space for himself
in a space and where there's already
established people
um it is absolutely fantastic what
you're doing and thank you so much for
joining us
again man appreciate it thank you thank
you so much i i really appreciate the
kind words i have been working really
hard so i really appreciate it i've been
i've been hustling as hard as i can
i do a lot of work into it and uh like
you said i'm i'm completely solo on it
so
thank you thank you so much been seeing
those live viewers and stuff into your
chat go
up it's been increasing i really
appreciate
it i really really appreciate it thank
you everyone
it's always a pleasure and we're honored
to always have you here to get your
perspective
again from a financial standpoint
industry standpoint it's really cool and
it's educational and
i think what you provide gamers the
information is
very important especially trends and i
love that you do it from a non-biased
perspective so salute to you
always i did have good around sir and
you know i put his twitter and there's
his youtube
i put them both back in the chat
definitely go there check him out
uh it's he's one of the i don't really
follow too many like you know analystic
guys but like i follow benji
absolutely we trust
don't get it twisted he could play a
mean guitar and beat your head
you can find me right after this podcast
going to taco bell for that
for the chance to get that series x you
can't
keep king put the put the faith in me
man he gave me that
faith that that little bit of energy i
need to get myself
into that car because i'm vacationing i
had to don't go nowhere when he's on
vacation
so get to get myself in that car go down
there and try to get that serious
accident
i'll post i'll post when i win you're
going to win
you're going to win you know we're going
to win lord king what's up
what can we expect from you this week
sir um
well i have a holy grail showing up any
minute now dhl has been
texting me telling me i got picked up so
i got a couple of stuff that's coming
this week
um uh like i said kos uh you can catch
me on darth castle x
uh fridays at nine p.m
definitely something to look out for the
best damn statue show
in the known universe it's funny as hell
we have miss dax on this week if you
don't know who mr x is go check out his
channel
um he's a different individual but check
out his stuff you might like it
all statue guys i i support 100
because it's not a easy easy hobby
cause a hell of a lot of money and
there's a lot of heartbreak involved
into it
[Laughter]
trust me when i tell you this when you
got to eat ramen noodles
but um shout out to benji for coming
through
man you know he knows his combat stuff
don't get it twisted because he was an
acknowledgement for certain things and
he
he understands what a chef checkup left
hook is so be careful with this man
he'll kick you in your leg and check
that [ __ ] you don't try to take his
series x from him
he understands the bare naked chokers
[Music]
shout out to benji for coming through
and hanging out with the lord it was
fantastic brother
no doubt the boss lord cog returns next
week thank you yeah
okay disclose location wearing an xbox
shirt
something like
holding it down in my absence washington
has been great
you know what's crazy you know what is
crazy about cognitive you took off the
two weeks of probably the the most
unhappy
it's a good thing we invested in the
second you know making sure
that the show must go on thing because
it would have been the worst two weeks
of the year to miss
listen he don't care he's in redmond
right now look at the patio
no i swear he got a swimming pool out
there he's looking over there
what the hell is going on time let's go
everybody again all the people are cross
paths with washington has been great but
i need to get
home also to the realm i get benji thank
you for coming through and last but not
least please
i need some love some positive thoughts
for um got some news from mama cockney
though she's not doing well
she's in the er still please send some
love away
yeah i just got the news maybe yesterday
i was with foggy when it happened
so you know she's hoping for the best
and it's not too serious
so i need some positive energy from that
y'all so that's it
um i'll be back hopefully on my fly out
tonight and um i will be back
in the states on the east coast uh
starting tomorrow and then uh i'll
alleviate solving addicts
um yeah for me you know where i'm going
i'm about to have lunch with my wife and
then
go go to work as i always do um yeah
shout out
and much love to mama cognito that you
know that that's a woman that's very
dear to my heart
so i hope everything is okay um and once
again cog thank you for
allowing uh trusting me with uh
with the podcast while you're going i'll
go i despise doing this but you know
i'm out of his show man we got the last
music blog
stay tuned stay tuned for the
sovereignty
all right so let me get these last
couple of super chats before we go yes
uh gamer by choice with the 10 super
chat i've been saying we should be
afraid of big companies
put all your favorite games behind
services or hardware pay walls like
amazon
buying take two google buying activision
uh etc yeah i mean that's a possibility
there's like benji said there's gonna be
a shopping spree
and we have mariano pompa with the five
dollar super chat in one of your live
streams benji you touched on game pass
numbers what does zenimax deal do to
game pass numbers
how many subscribers at the ee
eoi um so they basically they had 50
growth in less than six months which is
insane
right they went 10 million subs in april
up to 15 million in september so that's
insane it's almost around a million a
month
in terms of gains i think that they will
be uh by the end of the year
at 20 million plus subscribers easy wow
that's fantastic and we have some bits
and things with the five dollars of a
chat i knew cox surroundings were
different he graduated from that
platinum money to that redmond money
he's probably
getting he's probably getting a pedicure
mid podcast
amazon fumbled the xbox series xs
pre-orders and then released luna the
next day
they're playing dirty over there imagine
that
then we have the medic with the five
dollar super chat shout out to the iop
discord for helping me get my pre-order
also how xbox keeps this acquisition
quiet but almost nothing else
yeah man they think last minute i do i
think the
actual buy was last minute you think man
because dishonored two was like
was gonna leave game pass next month
like
no matter these deals let's go let's go
okay so these last couple of suits we
have gamers play uh with the final super
chat
what microsoft owns sony doesn't get
that's what the bethesda
bethesda co-founder said during a recent
interview okay so that is that
then we have shastri with the five
dollar super chat lord addict checkout
target
uh x is up for pre-order okay let's go
let's all go do that
no doubt guys thank you so much for
joining us we had over 600 over 700
people
over 700 people in watching the show
live today that is absolutely
amazing wow thank you guys we love you
we love the support we get we
come from 13. 13 people one of our
friends that didn't show up to be in
here
me cutting people off
don't hit my jack no more it goes
without saying that this is because of
you guys
every single week um so thank you so
much and we will see you next week
peace
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast as you guys may recall
a few months back king david otw
announced an amazing giveaway for the
xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away
another console at the end of this year
and that console will be a playstation
5.
you heard correctly so how do you get in
on this amazing giveaway
let me explain if you're already a
member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console
and if you support us on both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console
as you also have two ballots to win an
xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for
head on over to patreon.com go to the
ironlords podcast patreon page
become a member of the realm to get your
chance to win a playstation 5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have
a ballot to win a playstation 5 console
and if you want to support us on both
platforms you'll have
two ballots for each system to win
either a playstation 5 console or of
course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lord podcasts are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give
so much back to us so again if you're
not a member of the realm yet
what are you waiting for go out join the
realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next